so jen sackey is speaking to the press
she gets asked about the protest in
front of the supreme court justices
homes which is illegal
and she actually said that the
president's position is to encourage
peaceful protests outside of judges
homes
that's kind of crazy because that's
illegal we have the law we'll pull the
law up we'll show it to you and i get
these lefties they're like 10 years ago
you would have celebrated these protests
and i'm like oh yeah i mean they should
be arrested though civil disobedience as
i've always said results in arrest we
don't destroy your life and throw away
the key we arrest you to stop you from
doing the illegal thing it's called
non-violent civil disobedience it's a
tradition you go in the street you sit
down the cop takes you arrest you you
made your point you get the press
there's it's peaceful right they should
be arrested they're not getting arrested
and now the president is actually
inciting illegal behavior
congratulations that's where we're at
but
how about this
joe biden was also speaking about
inflation today and he said it's not my
fault it's the pandemic's fault and it's
putin's fault and you know what ultra
maga and then he started ragging on
ultra maga again and i'm just like this
this dude's lost his mind you know dude
i can give him
like okay i get kofi was bad i'm not
gonna blame biden for all the covet
stuff but then he's just like it's
maga's fault like maga's bad they're
gonna destroy everybody just just shut
up dude the the gas prices broke records
diesel has broken a record there's no
baby formula we got food shortages i
will tell you this if you're the
president of the united states
and dude who complains on internet has
been warning about food shortages for a
year now and y'all didn't do anything to
prepare for this
well then you know what am i supposed to
say am i supposed to am i supposed to be
like it's not biden's fault all this is
happening you know even i recognize this
a year ago talk about completely stupid
so we're gonna be talking about this
we'll talk about the economy and
everything that's really bad and we're
gonna talk about uh we're gonna talk
about congressional races redistricting
joining us to discuss all of this is
matthew foldy
guys great to be here i'm i'm running to
be the congressman from this area so
thanks for having me on tonight you are
trying to represent the place in which
this building is
yes sir so what what what's your
background that you want to introduce
yourself what's up beyond that well i'm
a fan of the show uh sort of the joe
rogan show of the east coast and uh
we'll hear that guys i like that yeah i
don't know i get really similar about
course yeah
um
so yeah i was a journalist until last
month and i'm from maryland from
montgomery county at the southern part
of this district here and uh basically
the governor of maryland larry hogan
fought the democrats in our state
capitol you know a lot of coverage about
redistricting says that only republicans
do this right but it's actually maryland
democrats are literally the worst in the
country they've been eliminating
republican congressmen all the time by
redistricting we've got maryland's sixth
district from before the redistricting
and you can actually see the
gerrymandering is insane they just
carved out all of the outer area of
frederick the city which makes it a
democrat district because that's those
are republican areas exactly and now
that restoring it has basically returned
western maryland which is trump country
i mean absolutely there is a gigantic
sign over here that is it's like trump
maga there's trump still ultra magnus
yeah ultra maga so uh this will be
interesting we'll talk about what's
going on with your race and who you are
and all that stuff we'll talk about all
that news thanks for hanging out we've
got we got shim sham shim sham over here
cast irl i run a youtube channel called
freedom tunes if y'all want to check
that out we upload satirical cartoons
every single thursday sometimes on
tuesdays as well i think you guys should
go over there check it out you'll enjoy
it i agree i agree i think they should
go there and check out freedom tunes and
while you're at it i am ian crossland
check out ian crossland.net if you'd
like to get involved or contact me in
any way and we'll get through there uh
see you soon and i'm very excited to
have a local politician on the show with
us this evening it's being a really good
conversation looking forward to it well
local to us but you're running for
congress you got it so that's federal
level that's not true yeah you're
correct because i was complaining to you
about maryland politics but you're like
yeah but that's annapolis it's like not
dc right look you can always complain
about maryland politics the democrats
here are absolutely insane whether
they're on a state local or federal
level in my county they removed school
resource officers from public schools
thinking that would make students safer
we then had the first ever school
shooting which i covered when i was a
journalist up until last month at the
free beacon this policy is such a
disaster that even democrats in
montgomery county said whoa whoa maybe
we're going to put school resource
officers back because that actually
makes students less safe having them in
there we got a lot to talk about in
terms of that so uh before we get
started head over to timcast.com and in
the top right you will see a sign up
button click that button sign up become
a member and i'll tell you why as a
member you're supporting our journalists
our op-ed writers and you will get
access to exclusive segments from this
show we'll have a special segment up at
11 p.m tonight members only is not
particularly family friendly friendly so
you've been warned a lot of swearing and
adult conversations about you know stuff
that youtube probably would be happy
with and you probably don't want your
kids to listen to anyway but there's
another reason why you should become a
member
we recently switched over
all of our hosting to rumble's
infrastructure because we need to do two
things we need to get away from the
sensorious platforms of silicon valley
and big tech that's one of the that's
the real first reason we were like we
better get on rumble because they will
try to ban us however it also means that
we are creating competition for silicon
valley by using rumble service by using
their video player for our members only
by using their cloud service for our
website and we have big news coming up
about future infrastructure changes
as a member you are helping businesses
that are on alternative infrastructure
so it's all just one more grain of sand
in that heap making sure that these
other these this new technology this new
tech sector can grow and compete with
with these sensorious lunatics of
silicon valley but don't forget you can
also smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and share the url to the
show or share the show wherever you can
right now grassroots marketing is is
amazingly powerful and um we've spent
zero dollars on marketing this show
up until this point we've got something
happening at the end of the month and
we're gonna do a bunch of silly and fun
things as i mentioned the culture
jamming is marketing and it's all thanks
to you guys who watch the show and as
members so we're going to keep on
keeping on but now let's get into that
first story and call out miss jensaki
and the president
so as many of you know there have been
protests in front of the homes of
supreme court justices it's overtly
illegal it's like unquestionably illegal
to do this
because
free speech
is or i should say justice is more
important than free speech so we
basically the idea from the founding
fathers and in precedent is you can have
your free speech but courts need to
adjudicate and if you try to protest
picket parade or whatever in front of a
member of the court's home in an effort
to intimidate or change those
proceedings you are committing a crime
it is a slap on the wrist crime no one's
going to destroy your life over this
it's like up to a year in jail which
basically i think it's a misdemeanor i
don't know how they do the laws in in in
the federal at the federal level but
these people should be arrested they're
not being arrested and more importantly
we have jen sackey encouraging illegal
behavior now look i get it non-violent
civil disobedience i'm mostly cool with
but that means people get arrested and
these people are not getting arrested
take a look at this clip the
post-millennial posted just listen to
jen seki yourselves actually i think i
got to fix i always got to make sure i
set the audio right i always just
doesn't play there we go there we go so
i know that there's an outrage right now
i guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position
the president's position is to encourage
peaceful protests outside of judges
homes okay well i'm just gonna i'm real
quick i'm going to read the law all
right
18 u.s
usca 1507 whoever with the intent of
interfering with obstructing or impeding
the administration of justice or the
intent of influencing any judge juror
witness or court officer in the
discharge of his duty pickets or parades
in or near a building housing a court of
the united states or in or near a
building or residence occupied or used
by such judge juror witness or court
officer or with such intent use any
sound truck or similar device or resorts
to any other demonstration in or near
any such building or residence shall be
fined under this title or imprisoned not
more than one year or both nothing in
this section shall interfere with or
prevent the exercise by any court of the
united states of its power to punish for
contempt it quite literally says any
other demonstration now look i'm not
saying these people protesting should
get felony charges in life in prison i'm
saying when you engage in non-violent
civil disobedience we recognize you're
going to get arrested for it you're
going to get a fine you're probably
going to get court supervision the judge
is going to say you can't go back and
that's it you made your point you did
something that some people would find
crossing the line you get your
punishment for it but nothing's
happening i kind of just now listened to
it for like the second time or the third
time i realized when she says and we
encourage that that people are
misinterpreting that that they encourage
the outrage against it that people like
no that's what she meant that they
encouraged the outrage but she obviously
if you listen to the way she speaks is
encouraging the people being outside the
homes of the judges well that's i don't
think anybody assumed otherwise yeah she
read it in text i could see how it could
get taken out let me let me show you
what the daily mail did on this one they
took her quote and they added hyphens
to change the context which is amazing
they say
i know that there's an outrage right now
i guess about protests that have been
peaceful to date
paused and we certainly continue to
encourage that pause outside of judges
homes as if to imply she's really saying
if they're going to be protesting they
should be peaceful instead of saying she
encourages the protests themselves
outside of judge's homes yeah i mean
what's the point of protesting outside
the house of an unelected judge are you
going to give him a constitutional
argument he hasn't heard of it's an
intimidation tactic it's so obvious it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if it's
an intimidation or not it literally says
influence the court influencing any
judge juror witness or court officer if
you go outside of a court and you try to
influence the judge juror witness or
court officer you get in trouble for it
this is only in relates to like physical
buildings being outside because like if
you try and influence them through the
internet like create a campaign of mass
people emailing or something that's
legal well this is specifically
picketing or parading and it says any
other demonstration
yo i'm just saying i don't think it's
the apocalypse i think they definitely
shouldn't go to people's homes i think
that's over the line but i just think
when you get to the point where the
january 6 trespassers not the writers
the writers i get you arrest those guys
but the people who had the doors opened
who have been locked up in solitary for
like six months to a year or longer some
of these people
and then it turns out the judge is like
oh the cops let you in your case
dismissed
the the boot that comes down
on the people on the right for basically
what what is a very similar law versus
the people who repeatedly and
continually do this and then are
encouraged to do it do it by the
president that the disparity in law
enforcement is absolutely insane yeah i
don't want to assume but i would imagine
that if there was another law being
considered and that it was just
something joe biden wanted to get passed
and people were protesting outside
judges they'd have referenced this
immediately and went and arrested them
all i don't know but that's the feeling
of this partisanry could you imagine if
like
proud boys showed up to a judge's house
they'd get arrested immediately domestic
terrorists insurrectionists they're
trying to burn the country down that's
all you would hear from me and not only
that but
it wouldn't simply be the case that they
would get arrested they would start
digging through tweets from conservative
politicians who said that they were
against this potential decision and
tried to charge them with insurrection i
mean we would and we would never ever
hear the end of it we would never hear
the end of it it would be in the news
cycle repeatedly remember when those
proud boys went outside that judge's
house
but because it's the left doing it
nobody cares they tried to like frame it
as a vigil which is like a silent thing
where you're you're standing vigil at
night you're keeping an eye out and
scouting and you're quiet while you're
doing it but if they're making noise
outside their houses it's just a full-on
protest this is actually just a
continuation of the biden 2020 campaign
right where they said okay
every illegal immigrant can come across
and get free health care right they said
that in the democratic primary debate he
raised his hand kamala raised her hand
during the 2020 campaign as you guys
were talking about this week they bailed
out rioters in minnesota including
rapists and pedophiles so it's not a
surprise that they're encouraging
lawlessness themselves here that's just
that is the democratic party is
obviously the party of defunding the
police it's a party of not enforcing
laws at what point
do we just start acting like there is no
government
let me elaborate
the media lied about kyle rittenhouse
they repeatedly said that he shot and
killed black people which was just not
true
they lied about what happened they they
they they just it was it was insane
watching the actual trial and seeing
those lies and i'm like okay these
people can't be argued with
they've made this story up in fact the
daily beast
used to be considered credible by
newsguard like 100 percent and then you
watch it slowly go down now they're
considered fake news at the right
exclamation point because they refuse to
correct all of the fake garbage they've
posted i wonder if the people at
newsguard which is like a news writing
agency are all getting red pilled like
crazy
because they're like the new york times
always tells the truth then they start
doing fact checking they're like guys
we had to actually fact check them and
they lied several times
so i'm looking at this
i'm looking at the the double standard
that you know we all perceive as people
who like the constitution and the
republic obviously there's no double
standard for the left because if it's
good for the revolution it's good if
it's bad for the revolution it's bad but
for us we're like hey we want laws
enforced equally i believe people have a
right to protest i believe you have a
right i i believe in leeway for
non-violent civil disobedience
but you at least expect there to be some
upholding the law so at what point
do people just say there's no point to
engage with the system
negotiate with
collaborate with or even
consider it would probably be starving
if there's a mass starvation it would be
like a desperation thing if something
like that were to happen i just mean
like what happens if people stop
participating in national level politics
in any sense because they're like this
is pointless
that's why you have representatives well
look look
here's what i want to say
with roe v wade as soon as these judges
got in you saw a bunch of red states
start passing these abortion
restrictions
and the left was saying you know this is
illegal it violates precedent you can't
do this
but the states were like we're gonna do
it anyway we've continually seen this
throughout the past couple of years
where red states and blue states just do
whatever they want regardless of the
federal government it is kind of the
impetus of the united states say hey man
the king king george was doing whatever
he wanted we were like yeah we're gonna
do what we want so that's the united
states yeah i mean parties are
generally selective
let it out sheamus
i can tell your point is gold thank you
no
it's like going to be the most boring
point i've ever made
no pressure when it comes to sanctuary
cities exactly
exactly right
we have my translator
decriminalization of certain drugs
they're completely fine to find defying
the federal government but if you do so
to protect unborn children then that's
illegal and they don't have any respect
for our political process
the the the the issue right now
just to i i i i everything keeps looping
back to the roe v wade things that's
what this protest is about but it's
conservatives are like states should
have the ability to choose and if blue
states want to pass you know
unrestricted abortion well then that's
their state's right that's that's
literally what the argument is right now
there are conservatives obviously saying
it should be banned out right but right
now in politics they're like return it
to the state legislatures and the left
is like no red states should be forced
to allow abortion
at what point do people just say like
dude
we're not going to participate with you
anymore and we're going to do whatever
we want what are you going to do about
it california's doing it already i'm
going to try again um
so yes i think that's the point in large
part they want anyone who isn't on the
far left to stop participating that's
the whole idea you don't get a voice
this government isn't here to represent
you it's here to force the ideological
whims of a small minority of this
country onto you it's the purpose of the
political system at this point the irony
of that though and i'll hearken back to
this a lot over the course of my
campaign is the democratic party is
literally being run from people's
basements and from their living rooms
the government is not being run in
person this was one of the stories that
i wrote at the free beacon i walked all
around the capitol for about 11 miles
walking and just simply taking pictures
and taking videos pulling on doorknobs
of the democrats health committee which
is closed to prevent the spread of germs
which is impossible
the senate armed services committee we
have some conflicts going on in the
world you might have been aware of the
foreign relations committee democrats
closed all of the government is being
run on zoom which is a huge national
security risk right all of the democrats
in congress up until a couple weeks ago
and the day after my story posted chuck
schumer opened his office but so all of
their dc offices are closed all of their
constituent offices around the country
are closed so you're right they're
trying to force conformity but they're
also hiding from accountability because
if you have a problem with how your
democratic member of congress like the
guy i'm running against david trone
you literally can't access him you go to
his offices and this is true of
democrats around the country there's
literally male just piling up you can
write to them you can be the most
pro-life person the most pro-choice
person they literally don't care they're
hiding from accountability they're using
the coronavirus to sort of be able to
withdraw from public criticism i just
think the system is just it's already
collapsed and we're kidding ourselves
that it hasn't it's changed we're for
sure using ancient ideas with modern
technology and it's not translating
because i think they they're they have a
right to work
remote you say that with an abacus in
front of your laptop i like it and i
will use it if the power goes out okay
that's part of why i have it um but
honestly i mean let's use the best
technology we have to communicate the
fastest the most efficient way possible
in my opinion and these these people are
still sending yeah but you need to be
able to talk to your representative
exactly
they need to be available to you that's
why like zoom like they should have an
hour a day where they take video chat
with people public video chats that's
the only way they're trying to run the
government is by zoom and you know my
grandparents have no idea how to do that
if you're if you're in parts of western
maryland where there's horrible rural
broadband problems you you can't
function like this i know all about
horrible broadband problems yeah
it took us like six months to get
internet out here yeah crazy i mean we
had like we had low quality internet to
give business i mean it was nuts and
with the new space we're building it's
just it's really difficult that's west
virginia but here's here's the issue i
don't i don't like the idea of zoom
government yeah i don't i don't like the
idea
that they don't need to look you in the
eyes and shake your hand and know you
have stood before them in their physical
space and said i live here and here's
what i expect from you that is important
like the king used to take court where
people would come in for several hours a
day and he'd be uh so bored just
listening to the problems be like okay
yeah you get the money okay yeah you're
the one in trouble and it works but it
doesn't scale when you have a three
million people that want to talk to the
guy the guy only has like you know 24
hours in a day i'll take a number the i
mean what are you gonna do it doesn't
matter if you're on zoom or otherwise
people can't if there's too many people
there's too many people the problem i
have and the reason why we don't do zoom
shows with irl is that it doesn't work
you don't get a real conversation i mean
you can have a conversation
it just it's not the same you can't it's
not the same but you can i had one of
michael malus a couple weeks ago episode
203 of your welcome and it was amazing
amazing to have a chance to talk to
michael for an hour it was amazing
amazing technology but i think part of
it is the fact that you two agree or it
wasn't going to be a hostile
conversation if you're having a
conversation with someone you disagree
with it's much easier to operate in bad
faith and to just try to get dunks and
smacks in if you're communicating with
them digitally rather than facebook
there's a reason is the way that audio
doesn't translate its binary so if i
speak while you're speaking one of them
cuts out there's a reason why in my
opinion whenever we try and get
prominent left personalities on the show
they always say i'll do it on zoom and
it's because what they're going to do is
once we bring them on the show and go
live they're going to cut out and it's
going to be someone else
that's what they've done and that's what
they want to do they want to just screw
around
and so there have been a few people who
have agreed to come on this show that
we've had on the show from the from you
know prominent left influencers
but all these other ones are like hey
why don't i just do it digitally and i'm
like because we've seen what you guys do
when you do these things digitally i'll
point out as an aside it shouldn't be
zoom if we do this it should be open
source non-proprietary so like jitsi or
element matrix or something like that
but
um to add your point yeah man there's
definitely a risk involved but when it's
it's like if you need to listen to a
bunch of people from around the country
it just it makes more sense i think to
do it to telecommute it than to make
them all fly out to dc and wait for hour
a day that's no one having district
offices though right that you don't have
to go to the capitol and yet all of
these democrats around the country you
know you can go to the closest office
here it's probably 30 minutes away in
hagerstown closed been closed for two
years
i think they they have to physically go
to d.c
where you're talking about the
representatives
oh yeah
i do not like the idea that they
telecommute to congress
and that's what they've been doing
and
you know it's it's like you see these
congressional hearings and like the tv
asked you a question sir
like no no in regards to congress itself
they should be together in person i
agree because you get more out of a
human to human contact but for just
listening to people's concerned citizens
i think that could be at least try it
yeah yeah i mean if if a citizen's going
to make a phone call leave a voicemail
send a message i want to watch your
videos on youtube sure sure that's great
on rumble i just think
elected representatives need to be
available to their constituents bingo
and pelosi under her rules in the house
they have been wildly abusing the proxy
voting system where you as a
representative say i can't come and vote
in person due to the coronavirus and i
reported on this extensively about the
abuses of the proxy voting system you'd
have eric swalwell saying that i can't
vote due to the coronavirus he'd be jet
setting around the country you pull his
campaign finance reports he's spending
in lavish hotels you have other
congressmen who are saying i can't
currently vote they're posting about how
they're in atlanta with joe biden for
mlk day so the proxy voting system has
been rampantly abused and it lets
democrats just shirk their
responsibility of voting in person let's
talk about what's going on in this here
country we got the story from npr from
wamu biden criticizes ultra maga
republicans as inflation rises
so basically he does the speech and he's
like look there's two reasons for
inflation the unprecedented pandemic
it's like i can give you some i can give
you that right putin's war
inflation was happening before putin's
war but it maybe kicked it up a little
bit then with food costs and everything
and then he goes on to say but the ultra
mega have no solution they're going to
raise your taxes cut your pay and make
all the problems and i'm like dude the
ultra magga like was three years of
prosperity the best numbers of our lives
so sayeth jim cramer and then the
pandemic happened and things got kind of
wonky so i'll give that to joe biden
when he's like the pandemic caused us
problems sure
but you know i mentioned it earlier
a year ago i was like guys
food shortages are coming it's going to
get bad
if dude on internet complaining can talk
about the food shortages and the
president could not do anything to plan
for or alleviate this then either he is
completely incapable of doing anything
about it and he should probably probably
say that i can't do anything sorry
you're out of food or he just didn't do
what he could have done because he's
incompetent and he could have done
something about it now let me show you
what we're dealing with
gas prices at record highs
perhaps when you have gas prices setting
records you shouldn't shut down
pipelines and you shouldn't ban fracking
but you know this is the game he's
played he's he he was very happy to help
russia's uh uh gas pipeline pre-war
meanwhile shutting down the keystone xl
and banning fracking on public lands and
then he says nothing i did caused this
and it's like well at least a little bit
dude come on take some responsibility
now you have this story from the ap
parents hunting for baby formula as
shortage spans us
so this is becoming a very serious issue
i can only say this
if the president is completely incapable
of doing anything about this then he
needs to come out and tell the american
people he should have told him a year
ago there is no policy and nothing i can
do to help you have a nice day of course
he wouldn't because it's not true the
reality is joe biden is just really bad
at what he does well and also if there's
nothing they can do about it they at
least have a responsibility to try to
warn the american people so that they
can prepare on their own i understand
that's difficult because there's an
argument to be made certain people are
going to start panicking but people
should at least know so that they have a
fighting chance i just think it's funny
that
when i do the shout outs for safe and
ready meals the emergency food stuff
which is like you know it's been kind of
a lot in these past several months
it is a weird phenomena among urban
liberals where they mock the idea of
buying emergency supplies
and now how many of them are going to
the store and they're like oh there's no
food
no food
what do you do i get really bothered
when they blame the pandemic for this
stuff and they because i feel like it
was the response to the pandemic however
you wanted to define that the response
to the virus the shutdown that really
caused this not the virus itself people
responded in a way where they shut down
businesses across the world for like a
year a year something crazy and yep and
now bill gates has come out and reversed
the entirety of his position
bill gates is spreading dangerous
disinformation oh no that you are not
allowed to say on youtube that's right
bill gates claimed can you believe this
that kovit is like the flu
no bill gates youtube will ban you if
you say that ultra magic you got to him
yeah
what if bill gates did just walk out one
day with like a hat on and he was like
i've been convinced guys yeah that's it
took me some time red pill gates yeah
guys tailgates he's back well this is
it's so typical though right because
all right so for a very long time the
left's argument was if you cut even one
penny of social welfare spending people
are going to die you monster and then
they said yeah we could just shut down
the entire economy for like a year and a
half that'll be fine no one's going to
get hurt if we do that well now we're
starting to see in a much more plain way
the ramifications of that and it's gonna
get really ugly and they're never gonna
take responsibility for this they're
gonna claim that this was just because
of covet and ignore the fact that it was
their insane disproportionate response
to it which failed to take into account
the unintended consequences it's just
funny i'm imagining you know joe biden
answering for all of the failures of his
presidency and at first he's like
impassioned like look you know it was
coven you know on president kovan by the
time you get to like the 87th failure
he's like uh that one was um
gnomes i guess i don't know somebody
somebody stole my socks
i slipped in the shower man slipped in
the shower major biden's phone yeah a
major bite yeah he's slipped in the
shower
i mean this is i just want to mention
this is and it's insane to even have to
explain this right but this is
a consequence of putting people in
charge of making decisions who will pay
literally no price if those decisions
turn out to be a disaster for somebody
else or if the effects of those
decisions turn out to be a disaster for
everybody else look where we are
matthew is just explaining how these
democrats offices are all closed
they're they're literally on vacation
not doing their jobs how much do you
want to bet people like swalwell he's
like he's gonna be like a capital grill
in dc or something like ruth's chris
steakhouse
and then you know he's talking and
they're laughing and he's like he's like
wait her another bottle of the dom
please and then his phone go his watch
goes burn and he goes oh i better tweet
so people think that i'm actually
involved in politics uh republicans want
to ban interracial marriage scent anyway
oh yeah
yeah firing off a banger
like they're checked out dude what a hot
take they're all checked out i have a
great example of that actually the sean
patrick maloney who's a democrat in new
york who chairs the house democrats
campaign committee he was he went to
france for va for a wedding at a
billionaire chateau
and while he was there he said mask up
we're all in this together we have to
defeat the virus he's literally partying
maskless at a french billionaire's
chateau defying a state department
travel warning against going to france
this is this is literally liberal
governance is you know it's the classic
rules for me but not for you but i you
know one of the sort of story lines that
i covered a lot was democrat mass
mandate hypocrisy because there are
never ending examples of this but this
is one of the most ridiculous i'd give a
shout out to ted cruz when that freeze
happened then he gets on a plane to go
fly to where was he going
and he was like oh is my daughter's my
daughter i i would have respected it
what he did if he just owned up to it
and said i'm going on vacation like and
you know i'm that's it it's happening
have a nice day instead he made it seem
like oh oh you know just just like own
it dude you know look if you want to go
on vacation i got no problem with that
what do you think your federally elected
representative is going to do for the
for these local issues i certainly think
it would have been better if he was
there for his constituents but i think
the bigger issue i have with him is
republicans aren't the ones screaming
about you wearing masks and not
traveling it's the left who is saying
you know travel is should be restricted
and you should wear a mask and do all
these things so when gavin newsom says
everybody has to wear a mask and then
goes to that you know french restaurant
not wearing a mask we're like hypocrite
when ted cruz is like i'm going if he
was just like i'm going on vacation i'd
be like okay well i guess sure instead
he's just like oh or it was my
daughter's and i'm coming back
you make me think about how you were
just talking before the show about the
um what was it the crack kits oh the buy
in crack pipes yeah biden administration
buy about these like safe usage kits or
whatever they're called specifically and
safe smoking and then they were like oh
there's crack pipes in these safe
smoking kits and they're like no biden's
administration is like no there's no
crack pipes but there were and then and
then what happened was behind the scenes
like quick get rid of the crack pipes
yeah and the people like well if there's
not crack pipes then it's not a safe
smoking kit because they're going to end
up using aluminum they're supposed to be
crack pipes in there why are there no
crack pipes turns out they were all
along and they just lied correct just
like ted cruz on vacation like you don't
need to lie to save face here we're all
in this together maybe
maybe sometimes but i think they do look
look ted cruz going on vacation is not
that big of a deal it was a national
news story i i it might it might look if
i was
like the representative and there's a
disaster in my district i wouldn't go to
cancun
but him going on vacation it's kind of
like well that's kind of a you know
stupid thing to do i guess that's about
it
when they realized giving out crack
pipes was like not a popular thing to do
they just lied and said no or not and
you're like safe smoking kids have crack
reps no they don't
they literally no they don't and then
the best part was when these left-wing
groups when they said there's no crack
pipes left-wing groups came out and they
were like why are you taking the crack
pipes
and i'm just like dude if they came out
and said yes there are crack pipes in
the crack safe smoking kits why because
they're clean and we're trying to limit
the spread of disease
then when someone says don't you think
supplying these could increase the
amount of like increase the likelihood
someone does smoke crack the answer is
it could i guess
i want to touch on that though for a
second so these are government-funded
crack pipes
and um one of them so i went to three
locations one in dc one in baltimore and
one in richmond none of them have any
effort at
prevention of saying you know maybe
don't do this the richmond one actually
when we went there uh with my colleague
he and i got there uh it was a van in
the in a hotel parking lot and they saw
two of us walking up and they said well
we we only have one more crack pipe but
we can give you guys
meth pipes and also cocaine snorting
kits and we said
sure we will take these things like all
three and they gave us a brochure and
they said we're an organization
dedicated to ending the racist war on
drugs there was nothing about how you
know maybe you should not do this if
you're having a problem you should call
these numbers but the biden
administration yeah after we reported on
how these the blind administration was
funding crack pipes um they went all out
against the free beacon normally this
would be called an attack on the first
amendment attack on the free press and
then they colluded with fact checker so
i'm actually way more black-pilled on
fact-checkers i think these are some of
the most useless people uh
they're they're incredibly useful to the
regime yes correct
good point but they are some of the
worst they couldn't make it in real
journalism so all they do is regurgitate
talking points from the left to get
articles removed from social media i
don't think they're journalists yes
they're democrat operatives correct you
know it's like what what was it there
was um
desantis said something what was it was
a fact check where he said oh yeah sixty
percent of college debt is held by
graduate you know people with graduate
degrees and politifact said it was fake
news
but the source from desantis was the
pointer institute which is like the
parent company of politics
and they were like he misunderstood we
we actually said something slightly
different and it was like
i can't remember exactly what they said
but desantis simplified the point which
they said mostly false it's what they do
the famous the famous line from bernie
and trump trump said something like this
50 unemployment in the in the inner city
and they said mostly false then bernie
said the exact same thing and said
mostly true
yeah right uh maybe not and maybe mean
the same thing this actually also
happened with tom cotton when he wrote
that uh stimulus checks would be
received by the boston marathon bomber
uh the washington post ruled this false
and then after it was proven true that
literally dzhokhar tsarnaev received a
1400 stimmy they then said oh this is
still one pinocchio
wow like we know this is true so
cotton's office went back and said ah
it's still false let's talk about why
they're freaking out though from the
pittsburgh post gazette elon musk says
that he would reverse twitter's ban of
donald trump
let me just spell this out
it is expected in three months
twitter will be owned wholly by elon
musk and he will unban donald trump that
means
whether trump intends to use the
platform or not he will be on the
platform the account will exist it will
be verified it will have followers all
the tweets will be there when the ban is
lifted
i think you know trump uh trump will use
it trump said before he's going to stay
on truth social don't believe it
i mean he'll probably stay on it he'll
probably use truth but he's going to be
on twitter and he's going to be tweeting
absolutely and the reason this freaks
them out so much
like you mentioned just a moment ago
with the facts checkers they need as
much control over the narrative as
possible
and what trump did
it used to be the journalists would get
the statement from the politician and
then choose how to report it
and if you were a politician
and you said something like
we'll play the game you'll be talking to
a reporter and you'll be like i had one
guy come up to me and say i don't like
i don't like eating cheeseburgers
and uh i thought it was a crazy thing to
hear than the newspaper article quote i
don't like cheeseburgers says politician
and the only thing you can do is say
they're lying it's not true and how do
you prove it with donald trump on
twitter he would just tweet
cheeseburgers are delicious it's fake
news and then people would be like okay
well trump just said it he bypassed the
narrative control the narrative machine
so he'll have to come back remember one
time he actually posted the full video
of an interview he did that he said was
going to be selectively edited so he
just released the entire interview
before they could get the ratings from
it what was that it was an abc news
interview
yeah well he just actually stall yeah it
was i think it was the leslie stallman
he's like yeah by the way we recorded
the whole thing here's the audio here's
the video
here's morgan just manipulated video to
make it seem like trump got angry and
stormed off did you see that
dude it's all it's all just lies man
since the beginning baby yeah yeah
that's part of why
i'm very surprised when anyone does sit
down with these interviewers especially
people on the right i can't imagine
doing something like that unless you'd
recorded it or were recording it and
have the right to release the footage
and sort of discuss that with them it's
insane to allow them to to filter you
yeah you got to have access to the media
like a direct line the technologies
available you've got to use it as a
politician in general i don't like these
things when the when they give emergency
beep warnings you guys hear that on the
audio yeah can you hear it this phone's
violated it's mine it's yours i feel
violated by that it's definitely mine
yeah my child abduction alert like i
didn't sign up for this
if you are in maryland the maryland
state police the request of the carroll
county sheriffs have issued an amber
alert for nine-year-old savannah rosetta
nicole heaton a white female the child
clothing description is unknown the
child was last observed at approximately
6 p.m in the westminster area of carroll
county the child me may also be in the
baltimore area
well thank you i don't for pointing that
out that helps a lot of people well
exactly i figured if we're getting the
alert right now and there's somebody in
the area we just blasted that message
out there hopefully it helps brother
yeah i don't want these creepos again
these kids
okay all right well anyway what were we
talking about the importance of media
going around you were saying people need
to have access to
people to be able to get out yes and it
should not be mandated but like how long
should a politician have to listen to
people every day two hours i don't know
but in order to clarify what people say
about you you've got to have vocal
access to masses unfettered well that's
why shows like those shows like rogan
are such a threat to journalists and you
really saw this with the coordinated
assault on joe rogan in particular
because he is the most listened to
person
in the northern hemisphere right he his
show was displaced recently from the
number one spot yeah batman beat him
yeah batman beat them
yeah it's a batman podcast oh my god
it's like a weird batman podcast or
something which which batman is it or is
it uh robert
is it the lego batman
i don't know sheamus which batman is oh
i have no idea why would i know i don't
know because you sounded like you knew
this is psychology you look the most
like robert pattinson of anyone in this
oh my gosh how dare you
it's called batman the audio adventures
oh my god scripted podcast from dc
entertainment hey that sounds fun a lot
of zealots out there wait until they
pull out bruce wayne's old tweets and
they'll just
i mean you're driving in your car and
you want to listen to something
yeah but not joe rogan
but wait until batman becomes a threat
to the establishment exactly
batman's just like vote for trump i'm
pretty sure batman was a threat to the
establishment exactly but not right now
i mean look they're letting him be
number one on spotify no batman wasn't a
threat to the establishment he would go
up on the roof of the police building
and collude with the police and
everything some of the police look
that's back when the police were uh you
know doing their job probably i think
they were [ __ ] some of them not the
ones he was talking to he made what
happened to harvey dent in the dark
knight true that's true gordon was
awesome though yeah he was a good to
this day
gordon what's his name is that his first
name jim gordon jim gore jim gordon
elon musk is not like batman he's like
iron man he's like iron man which brings
us back to elon musk
taking control of twitter i can't wait
for all the brilliant think pieces about
what a threat it is to democracy to
allow donald trump on twitter i can't
wait for them to light up their biden
given crack pipes that's why i was
saying before
the system has crumbled and collapsed
already
it's fake outrage it's the weirdest
thing
when
you you know what i'm gonna stop right
there it's simple
if you are on the right
you know the left's arguments you've
engaged with them if you are on the left
most likely you have not heard the right
wing argument and you have not engaged
with i would tell you i think what they
think the right wing argument is is that
and this i don't want to deal the
conversation in religion but it's that
jesus's mother got impregnated by a
ghost and they're like do these yeah
you're putting it in an intentionally
way exactly this is what they think they
give people that you and other
is that they believe that a girl got
impregnated by a spirit and so how can
we take that seriously how can i take
that seriously it's it's it's because
you think you so you think
a belief that mary was impregnated be
the holy spirit is why the left doesn't
like the right my understanding that's
part of the dis
i think ian i understand what you're
trying to say but i think you're being
actually too
um what's the right what you you're
being you're giving them do you bring
too generous
the left wouldn't say mary wasn't
pregnanted by a ghost they would say the
right is about are a bunch of bronze age
crackpots who believe in old fictional
it starts with i just picked that as one
thing that i'm like what okay let's talk
about it but it spirals into like oh and
then they're crazy about this and this
is this and this you're definitely wrong
ian because they don't they would also
say that men can get pregnant so you
know a woman got pregnant you'd be a
birthing person you know all of these
sorts of things it does bring up
abortion topic about abortion and holy
conception there's a meme
and it says
my religion says i can't do this so i
won't and they say that's good for you
and they say my religion says you can't
do this and they say f off and that's
the argument they've been using for roe
v wade because they've never actually
asked a pro-lifer what's their position
they then say on twitter republicans are
engaged in fake outrage
i look at that and i'm like it's really
weird because you know we talked to so
many people on the right on this show
we've heard their arguments articulated
we've heard the left articulate their
arguments but their arguments are based
on not knowing what the rights arguments
are and they don't come on the show
shout out to daryl davis who we had on
the show a lot of people were not happy
with things he had to say but he did say
something very important he was invited
to a dinner
with the far right and the far left
whatever that means and he said you know
clan members and nazis all showed up
and then when he got to this dinner to
have a conversation he was the only
person from the left who showed up
they don't engage they don't know what
the right things they're not arguing
anything i think oh i think it's a type
of dismissal like they don't they don't
take it seriously because of the
religious stuff
no no i i think that's what it is i'm
trying i mean i'm trying to figure out
like everybody else but that's no
interesting they they say don't platform
don't you legitimize it i i think the
real issue is
i was in um
what was i in san bernardino there's a
protest trump supporters were protesting
so antifa shows up
i walk over to the leftist side where
they're all protesting and i saw people
standing around and i walked over and
was like i was like how's it going guys
then all of a sudden someone yells mike
check and then the entire group goes mic
check and they go do not do not everyone
repeats it talk to talk to anyone anyone
they will try they will try to confuse
you to confuse you and then i was like
does anybody want to tell me it's a mic
check mic check mic check my and then
they chant for about 30 seconds to a
minute i'm like okay and i walk off i'm
not exaggerating they did it they did
this at occupy wall street it is a
tactic of leftist organizers to prevent
the regular people there from hearing
anything someone might have to say no
that's a mob mobs for sure are near
impossible to communicate with of any of
any mindset but if you just get a
one-on-one conversation with two people
one from the left and one from the right
i think that if you come to a middle
ground it might have the religion might
be part of it i i certainly think so for
some people
that they don't understand but the core
is
they don't understand
so i was in berkeley after one of the
big protests
and i was standing on a street corner
filming and i was talking to some guy
when a leftist woman came up and started
pushing back on the things that were
being said
so i turn around holding my camera
and she started saying things and i was
like a woman
was shoved off she was standing like two
feet off the ground on a light post
standing on like the base of it and
someone shoved her and she fell down hit
her head and got blood everywhere
and she was like yeah well she shouldn't
have shown up here and then i was like
you think she shouldn't have allowed to
be here she's like she's a trump
supporter and she knew coming here would
get her attacked and then i was like
really so do you think if like a woman
wore provocative clothing and was
walking down this alley and she got
attacked by some guy because the way she
looked that's her fault too and she was
like
yeah i think so
and then i was like okay
and then
after i was like well thank you and have
a nice day she walks away in about a
minute later she comes back and says
delete that footage delete it and i was
like i'm standing on a public street and
you talk to me i'm going to use it now
i'm not i don't try to dox people
anything so i blurred her face because
the idea is what is what's most
important i don't need people going to
this random woman who's talking on the
street the point was when this woman
from the protest was by herself and
decided to speak up she had no idea what
her positions were and she actually
agreed with blaming women who get
assaulted for the way they dress if the
video is on my tim cast channel
somewhere you can find it and that's the
gist of the conversation
i think when you go to these protests
having been too many of them these
people don't know anything
i'll tell you my favorite
my favorite was antiqua pizza
during occupy wall street when they
would go ah auntie antica pitalista
and then i saw a guy and he's going ba
abita nida bitsto and i was like hey
what are you chanting he was like oh
i just you know
i'm like you don't know what you're
saying nobody knew what was being
chanted except for the organizers so
when they're screaming anti-capitalist
and these other people who just showed
up because they saw it on social media
or the news and they're just muttering
and mumbling
that's my experience with these protests
it's a religion it's like they're going
to church and just trying to follow them
no no no teachings without knowing what
he's saying so they're just
i think that's unfair
because having also been to churches the
people have books where they can reach
churches
that's for sure i developed this theory
when i was in college
i went to university of chicago where
bernie sanders went and there's a famous
picture of him
getting arrested
protesting uh as a college student he
looks exactly the same as he does now
and uh he was protesting the school had
segregated housing and so he was
arrested protesting this and that's a
good thing to protest now the problem is
for students who are there now there's
nothing on that level of things to
protest about but they still want to get
that photo of them being arrested so the
president of the university of chicago
the student president when i was there
one year he chained himself to a
building in downtown chicago because he
was demanding right after trump won he
was demanding that our democratic
senators dick durbin and tammy duckworth
vote against the confirmation of betsy
devos for education secretary which they
did and they were always going to do he
got arrested he got the photo he
literally looks like a limp noodle so
it's not like you know bernie was
looking resolute this guy looks totally
pathetic he gets arrested held overnight
and then i hear him the next day telling
his leftist activist friends about this
and i said to him oh this sounds a lot
like white privilege you just got
arrested and just you're completely back
out on the street next week and the next
day and he said
no no no no it's not i mean it was every
every activist wants that you know the
left is all about instagram that's all
they care about is getting that
instagram story the instagram
infographic so being there in that
protest is what matters not actually
what they're saying so i remember um
we talk about the algorithmic problem on
youtube where hitler was doing tai chi
with the incredible hulk
because people were just trying to find
ways to make viral content
because of politics the virality of it
because of coven because of uh politics
as pop culture
we are now seeing young people
claiming to be strategists or involved
in politics because they know
it is a path to virus to virality
so there's this guy who's going viral
now with a bunch of videos where he just
like looks at the camera all angry and
furled and he's like it is a violation
of federal law to commit perjury merrick
garland what and and the right makes him
go viral conservatives start posting
like haha look at this guy and it's
working
so this dude is getting made fun of
the left then sees that and they're like
we're going to prop this guy up because
the right's targeting him and he's
calling for the arrest of people we
don't like what's going to happen in 10
or 15 years when politics is all just
reality tv
it is going to be worse than idiocracy
you think president camacho was bad
camacho was a good dude you guys you've
seen an idiot yeah he was camacho might
have been shout out to terry crews he
was a good if you watch idiocracy he was
actually trying to help people he was a
nice guy and he was he was just not
smart now we're gonna have something
worse
donald trump was the beginning of
reality tv politics you are going to see
it be the most insane
youtube drama tick-tock drama
politics you've ever seen
and then people are going to start
punching each other in the face i
remember the youtube cnn debates in 2008
we talked a lot about in videos internet
youtube videos at the time like hey guys
we have the technology let's interact
with our public officials now let's have
like a a virtual let's do this for real
and let the world see and so cnn got
involved all of a sudden now cnn's
curating what questions get asked so you
know i send a question about the federal
reserve to barack obama because i want
to hear what he thinks about it for real
and they don't use that question they
use questions like real real surface
level and you know a nice reality tv
twist to politics that was like the
beginning and then of course trump got
elected in 2016. and what's the biggest
problem one of the biggest problems i'm
seeing is when you get into congress you
become famous and then your twitter
account goes huge forever that's not
true they all know who every every
congress person that i've have heard
their name i go to twitter they have a
million a million or more subscribers
because you've heard their name yeah
every musician i've heard of has so many
followers they can leave congress and
now they're famous and they can get a
book deal and have followers
how many members of congress are there
400 and something 435 435 right
um can you name 20 of them probably if
you give me some time are you a fan of
congress name 20 of them
that's something i have 20 congressmen
to be allowed obviously we all know who
alexandria ocasio-cortez is
but
the rank and file members sure sir i
submitted name a member of congress from
uh
iowa
oh i can't one of them just endorsed my
campaign marionette miller meeks oh he
knows it yep
i worked at the house republican super
pac before this so iowa's congressional
delegation is
marinette miller meeks cindy axne the
lone democrat ashley henson and randy
feenstra cindy accidentally is the lone
democrat representing the state of iowa
her office in des moines is completely
close to her constituents just
as i reported at the free beacon but yes
uh those are the four members of
congress from iowa name name
don't say it okay name the member of
congress congress who represents this
district we're in oh i do that's not i
don't that's not how i think i just know
like the the reality starts but you get
my point yeah well let me ask you about
even the member of congress for the
district we are in right now is not
famous it's the ones that are making big
news because it doesn't work they're
being crazy they're like loudmouth
elizabeth warren you know cortes ted
cruz
district that's a vacant district
because the member had to resign that
was jeff fortenberry it will now be mike
flood oh interesting yeah well i'm just
pulling up random districts well this is
what i do for fun pull up random
districts well no i just know random
members of congress so nebraska's
delegation don bacon from nebraska's
second district he has also endorsed my
campaign uh and then the third one is
jeff vordenberry resigned and then uh
lee terry is the other one
i'm blanking on the third district right
now but nebraska's no there is no fifth
district it's just three there's no
fifth not anymore oh interesting there's
only three now three oh okay
but what what i'm seeing is like a race
it's a race from the uh some of these
people to become to make news so that
they become famous so that they get
twitter followers on their personal
account and i don't think that's just
about
30. uh i i disagree
uh most members of congress you've never
heard of
yeah but i think that there's an
incentive for people to go kind of
haywire and make a big splash in a scene
and like spectacle so that they get
famous so that they have a parachute in
case they leave congress here's a great
example of that is jamie raskin in
maryland who's uh always on msnbc that's
sort of what he's there to do if you
have a problem uh and you're a
constituent of his and you go to his
office in rockville it's closed it's
locked i reported on this he when i went
in the middle of the day there was a
note jammed in the door frame from
someone who tried to access their
representative and said hey congressman
raskin you know i'd like to meet with
your office about something i went on a
friday morning at 11 a.m straight up no
one there i rang the doorbell like 20
times completely empty let's talk about
this district here actually so oh yeah
so we got um matthew here matthew foldy
and you're running in maryland's sixth
congressional district you're running as
a republican of course and you're in the
in the primary which is july 19th 70
days away so check this out this was one
of the most interesting things that we
saw so
actually i don't is there a way that we
can zoom in on this yeah here we go so
this is the uh we i zoomed in pulled up
the uh current this is the current
district map right this is for this
election yeah all right let's uh let's
do this from 2013 to 2023 here's what
you can see it's really interesting
this whole uh grayed out area of western
maryland which is the it's called the
panhandle right yep
it is overwhelmingly manga country you
drive out through here all these places
it is maga country there are some areas
where you'll see some progressive stuff
you know you've got like i think i don't
know that's west virginia virginia but
there's there's certain areas where it's
like right next to the like there's some
cities and there are some colleges
right so take a look at this
look right here look at this weird carve
out
frederick is very democrat but outside
of it
typically like in any suburb you'll see
more cons more conservative more
republican bingo so this is what it was
from 2013 until 2023 but from 2023 it
has been that's all they did
all they did was put back the suburbs
into the exact same space and guess what
happened tell them what happened well
now it's a republican district and you
guys have never heard of the democrat
david trone right there who represents
this place because he literally does not
show up for work his offices have been
closed for two years he does not live in
this district he does not vote in this
district while all of his
taxpayer-funded constituent offices in
allegheny washington frederick and
montgomery counties are closed and
locked male piling up gathering dust he
literally hosted joe biden at his
mansion in potomac for a fundraiser last
night no masks in person so it's too
dangerous for him to do the job we pay
him for but he can host lavish
fundraisers for the ticket cost went up
to thousands and thousands of dollars
but god forbid he show up and actually
represent the people of western maryland
so this is the crazy thing this district
the the bulk of its population from 2013
to 2023 was the dc suburbs
which is democrat absolutely after they
decided to put the frederick suburbs
back in it's now a republican district
but it still includes the dc suburbs
less of them less of them but but i
think that's abs i think that's that's
that's fascinating how gerrymandering
works like that they they put in a tiny
piece of dc suburbs cut out frederick
suburbs and boom you got a democrat
district maryland democrats in the past
20 years have surgically eliminated
republican after republican after
republican from congress maryland you
all think of this as a democratic
stronghold in 2000 maryland had four
democrats in congress and four
republicans then they eliminated two via
gerrymandering after the 2000 election
then they eliminated roscoe bartlett who
represented this area of western
maryland for decades john delaney wins
dan bongino almost beats him in 2014.
then david trone comes in in
and he's been representing this area
since then and he doesn't even live here
he doesn't even live in the district you
know he's never voted for himself he's
so bad he has never voted for himself in
an election that he has won wow
well i guess he won't be representing
this district by the end of the year
because you're running and i got to tell
you man having worked out here for so
long uh my residence is in west virginia
we're setting up the new h the new
headquarters is already
under construction with some operations
in west virginia as we speak
and we're planning on totally relocating
everything because maryland is
apocalyptically bad for business
that's just the easiest way to put it it
saddens me there's so much potential
here and you see it all around us right
here but the democrats in annapolis are
hell-bent on ruining the advantages that
we do have in this the people who live
around here there's like it's it's it's
relatively sparsely populated but i just
keep hearing from everybody that i want
to be here anymore
because these are the people who live in
western maryland it is maga country
it is outright manga country like the
things i've heard from some of the
locals out here i'm kind of like whoa
whoa whoa calm down like wow you know
just the things they talk about talk
about democrats and so now i'm hearing
they're just like it's time to move west
virginia is a hop skip and a jump away
and west virginia supports trump and
supports freedom and liberty and the
constitution but not maryland and they
gut your business
that it's just it's absolutely insane
they don't want you to be here
this is because they're they're
legislating for the east part of
maryland like the dc suburbs but then
everyone's getting hit by the
legislation exactly not necessarily i
mean i think if you i i was surprised to
find out we we uh
the the people who choose to live in
annapolis in in eastern maryland i'm
just like why
it is it's it's
the taxes are insane why would you
choose to live here
that's i just don't know it's
unfortunate i mean maryland is i mean
you know anyone from maryland we have
the best day flag and we're probably the
best state but look the democrats here
are
awful as as they are in most places when
they're in charge and uh so we have
incredibly important elections for state
legislature in maryland this year for
governor this year for congress this
year so we finally have a chance of at
least getting on the federal level
representation literally that actually
will show up and listen to western
maryland and this part i mean this part
of the state everything west of
frederick in particular is a complete
afterthought to the democratic party so
when i've been out there
people are astonished that someone who
is running for office on a federal level
a is a republican and b actually shows
up to listen to them well do they know
that the redistricting has created a
republican no and it's so important to
tell them because for the past 10 years
they've had no vote that actually
matters and now i'm saying look you guys
actually have this primary is incredibly
consequential you guys can send someone
to washington who will actually show up
investigate the binded administration
force accountability and listen to you
and help you with the problems that you
guys have were you like when you were a
reporter before you were a reporter did
you get inspired at some point to get
involved in the process or was that
something you'd wanted to do before i've
been involved in maryland politics since
i was in high school i didn't really see
myself running
um but i heard from all of the
candidates who are running against david
trone because i am the president of my
county young republican or the vice
president of my county young republicans
now and none of them even talk about
trone and i worked at the house
republican super pac prior to becoming a
journalist for two years and you know i
know that republican candidates have to
lead the way on making issues about the
democrats and everyone else in this race
doesn't even mention trone's name on
their website meanwhile i'm going
through thousands of pages of legal
documents that's going to show a whole
mess of problems for him that we need to
inform voters i've i've found that if
you complain about the other person it
gives un like free press to them like
hillary spent way too much time talking
about trump that's why he won yeah she
just talked about what she wanted and
was going to do and then create the
story about her yeah that's the key yeah
you know what you do is you you have a
debate and you don't invite the
incumbent
well he probably won't show up anyway or
if he does it'll be on zoom and just
have a little no just don't invite him
don't worry about him yeah i'd love to
see him get a different democrat and
then be and then people will be like
that's the democratic you guys can come
on the show together i love it i mean
look he's you're currently david trone's
constituents and he doesn't know it and
you didn't know it but we should do a
debate right we already have an empty
chair yeah exactly
i don't i don't live in the district but
we work in the district and the district
the state just is constantly just i feel
like the state of maryland
is just whacking us with a switch over
and over again saying get out get get
out get out of our state and i'm like
okay stop geez okay i gotta grab that
stick no then it's double possession
dual possession yeah yeah try to avoid
the stick so you're going to repeal the
nfa if you get the chance which is the
nfa the national firearm oh i hope so i
mean any any gun that has any bill that
has anything to do with guns is almost
always going i mean
unless it's a bill to
mandate everyone get a free gun that
would be great that would be a mandate
that actually is good but with the
supply chain crisis we have right now we
probably will not be getting what are
some of your ideas like or do you have
ideas going in things that you can
actually do and i'm not super familiar
with the process so tell me about it so
look for we're going to take the house
back take the senate back and then we're
stuck with biden for the next two years
so to me as i envision the
uh the first term it is laying the
groundwork for a republican president to
win and a lot of that means doing actual
oversight of the biden administration in
my reporting i've actually led to
multiple investigations into both the
energy department and the commerce
department and the border so to me i
sort of think of this as cutting out the
middleman i already know sort of at
least the initial places of where to
look for where there's smoke there's
fire and it's you know
green energy it is the border and things
like that so i want to do actual
meaningful oversight with consequence
and going back to your point about the
media
there the reason i think that liberals
don't really know conservative arguments
is because they can go their whole lives
without meeting any of us so i went to
an event in silver spring which is very
liberal in montgomery county when i was
a reporter or the secretary of energy
whose corruption i've been exposing
going back basically since becoming a
reporter and there was a whole crew of
journalists there was an event to
promote a house with solar panels and so
after the event is over i walk up to the
energy secretary i said secretary
granholm great to meet you i'm a
reporter so she automatically assumes
i'm liberal i'm very young so she
assumes i'm liberal and i said hey i
just wanted to know who is that mystery
buyer that you sold one uh 242 000
shares of non-private proterra stock for
a non-disclosed for a self-disclosed
profit of 1.6 million her staff was on
me
like like it was nobody's business and
they whisked her away and this is
awesome reporting i've done basically
she owned millions of dollars as energy
secretary of a private company that she
and the biden administration was
promoting while she was in charge of
that exact industry so my reporting
forced her to liquidate her shares a
couple of weeks before the
company went public which cost her tens
of millions of dollars this is the sort
of thing we actually should be doing and
if this had been a trump administration
official you guys would know exactly
what i'm talking about but my point is i
showed up i think that democrats assume
that conservatives and conservative
journalists in particular like don't
exist and we just sort of dwell
in basements on the internet and that we
don't actually appear in the wild
because when you see the journalists who
are interacting with the white house
with members of congress they're all
just as you said in democratic party
activists not actual journalists or
truth seekers i have a question for you
uh
when you get elected are you gonna move
would you vote to impeach joe biden
i don't i don't think impeachment is
good especially because we'd get kamala
uh running the show and that would that
would be bad yeah but i mean
i guess my issue with that is
do you just let someone get away with
illicit activities because someone else
might be worse or do you just say we
have to uphold the law regardless of the
outcome i kind of like the latter more i
i don't i mean after we saw democrats
basically waste two years of the trump
presidency trying to impeach him twice
i'm not really convinced it's that
effective a
thing to do i'd much rather expose
corruption and sort of see where that
goes but
yeah i think after seeing how
destructive impeachment is i mean
there's no doubt the biden
administration is lawless and has been
promoting lawless activity since he was
a presidential candidate i don't know
how effective a use of our time that is
so
before he becomes president or in the
previous administration in the previous
previous administration
hunter biden is on the board of an
energy company he's getting 83 000 a
month it's been reported
victor shoak and the prosecutor
was investigating michola zlatchevsky
the founder of barisma
i believe they're around a dozen or so
open uh active investigations some were
like temporarily suspended or on hold
but they existed matthew jb reported
that so fact check me on that one
because i i mean if the number's wrong
joe biden comes in after an email was
sent between one of these consulting
firms
and then he uh tells the the the
president to fire the prosecutor
otherwise he's gonna withhold a billion
dollars in aid from the u.s government
which he doesn't have the authority to
do
so joe biden is doing what is very
obvious
and uh most people believe should be
investigated donald trump said take a
look into this and what happened they
impeached him
now as president joe biden every over
the past three months has been asking
for tens of billions of dollars to be
given to ukraine
this is
in my opinion evidence of malfeasance
sure enough i mean i get it ukraine's at
war
but how fascinating that the guy who's
asking for favors who's got his kid
running these businesses with barisma is
now all of a sudden using taxpayer funds
for a non-ally non-nato non-eu nation in
their conflict
this dude is in my opinion committing
very very serious and obvious crimes
should he be at least be investigated
which dude
the investigation i mean yes i mean we
obviously have to look into into any
possible
yeah corruption i think
yeah um i think he's i i think i in my
opinion
is that he's stealing money from the
taxpayer to pay off his buddies and
that's what he's been doing since the
beginning of this whole operation
i think that um i mean we need to
actually investigate
any corruption whether it is in the
binder family i mean some of the
reporting i did was also want other
people you've never heard of like joe
kiani who is biden has said in one of
his speeches in 2015 this is one of my
closest friends he gave he has given
millions of dollars to biden ventures
whether it was the biden institute at
penn whether it was the biden super pac
the biden presidential campaign oh lo
and behold this company is getting
millions of dollars of federal contracts
from the biden administration and he's
on a prestigious biden board for science
and technology advisor so i think that a
lot of the corruption that i've reported
and that my colleagues at the free
beacon have reported on would again be
national news like joe kiani would be a
national figure like scott pruitt was
during the trump administration he'd be
a national figure if all he did was
shine trump's shoes yes that's true and
then do something impressive exactly so
look i think that actual oversight is
incredibly important to do whether the
president is a republican or the
president as a democrat and democrats we
know will not do any of this because as
i've also reported they literally don't
show up for work let alone actually
going after their political allies in
this administration so i think there the
sky is the limit when it comes to
corruption in the administration i'm 25
but i can tell you with confidence this
is the most corrupt administration of my
lifetime and i think it's important for
us to show the american people that so
anyway so your question that is an issue
is forcing good government but then also
stopping the reckless spending that's
destroying our economy via inflation
that the administration denies crushing
communist china stopping giving iran
nuclear weapons actually promoting
american jobs and american energy the
department of energy of course doesn't
actually believe in energy it's
incredibly hostile to american energy
and american energy creators so the
first step is to stop a lot of the
madness that we're seeing from democrats
and the biden administration and then we
can start laying out sort of a vision of
hey here's why you guys should give us
the white house but the first thing i
think is
staunch the bleeding and then proceed
accordingly have you heard of graphene
graphene have you heard of graphene uh
no it's a carbon
that's one atom thick this is it
actually right here it's a wonder
material it's going to be the steel of
the 21st century and we can get the
united states on board with creating
this stuff and mass will become a global
superpower what do you what do you think
for 2024 trump or desantis i i like in
all the above energy solution i haven't
heard of that though um materials
science it's the way to go that's how
you win elections i like it um i think
2024 is light years away so let's like
right now the most important election
for me is july 19th in this primary then
november 8th
um desantis has to win this year right i
mean it's going to be a red wave but
just keep in mind having this
conversation in 2014 we were probably
talking about people who were going to
go on to lose that year so obviously
desantis will destroy whatever they
nominate but something crazy could
happen with him something crazy could
happen with trump so first
let's
have the red wave like we can't take
advantage like we can't forget
that we have an election this year
by getting distracted by the shiny
object of 2024 yet we got to win this
year how much of it is like what
idealistic what you want versus the
the political game the football game of
who's there how can i get this many
people to do that that's a really good
question i have no idea
um
i'll come on as a member of congress and
i'll get back to you i literally don't
know you know sort of circle back mr
smith go well no but honestly i'm not
going to lie and say oh i can tell you
what it's going to be like to be a
congressman as a 25 year old i am
incredibly idealistic and maybe that
means i'm somewhat naive
but i think that having people go who
want to get in there on day one and
start investigating corruption and
making a difference you know it matters
who we elect right that's why i jumped
in this primary is i was like look i'm
25 but i have no doubt done more to
expose democrats corruption and
malfeasance than anyone else in this
race and that's why we have to actually
send someone watching who wants to do
that i i think the the problem for uh
the problem that many of us see the
democrats corruption is fairly obvious i
mean look jimmy dore who's a leftist
yeah and he rags on the democrats all
day and night even hassan
he rags on the democrats all the time i
think we all can see the problem with
with democrats the problem i have with
republicans is that they're a barrier
preventing actual
america like pro america
pro american worker politicians from
getting in
you see what's happening with robbie
starbuck yeah absolutely the machine of
the republican party just wants to be a
machine a fat gluttonous power absorbing
machine that does nothing to help
anybody and we heard this from i think
it was thomas massey marjory taylor
green freedom caucus basically that
actually no no who who's the other guy
we had from the freedom caucus
i don't remember his name was his name
was it randy or something yes it was
randy weber randy weber yeah i think it
was him he was saying that he could have
been the vote to over to to repeal uh
obamacare but they were like no no no no
don't do that don't do because we need
the issue
we need to pretend we're fighting
against something that's the problem i
see with republicans i think democrats
are the same way but so long as we have
the standard republican leadership
nothing's going to change well that's
why i think it's important that we
actually not only flip the house but it
depends who we're sending there and so
you know when i'm talking to people when
i'm going knocking they're going to say
oh you're 25 that's really exciting but
you know
what can you actually do
and i say look yeah you're right i'm 25
but i think
sort of our generation of people does
not is not as beholden to sort of that
type of politics as we've been used to
for i think all of our lives whether
it's because we're way too idealistic or
already way too cynical in blackbuild um
you know i think a lot of the same old
same old doesn't really fly with us
here's what i think is going to happen
i think if
you do get in yeah and you do not
go after joe biden with impeachment
investigations and an attempt at
attempted conviction
then
it's going to be the republicans being
like we don't want to destroy everything
we don't want to waste time and then the
democrats will keep doing it yeah then
the leftists will claim the republicans
of the scorched earth party while the
republicans are the washington generals
and then i see people like kyle kalinski
claim the democrats are actually the
washington generals and i'm just like
yo
in 2016
uh you know after after the midterms
when the republicans had basically
everything
they went along with russiagate
when donald trump sees obvious issues
with ukraine he gets impeached and the
republicans do nothing when it comes to
the 2020 election across all of these
states republicans cut deals with
democrats to change voting laws
if the republicans are unwilling to play
politics in the same way
then it will be the same thing democrats
will keep steamrolling they will keep we
will keep seeing changes that are
negative it is just a slow roll and in
20 years republicans will be transgender
communists who have sacrificed all their
values because they'll keep lurching
leftward
however
i believe if the republicans do decide
we're going to impeach joe biden we're
going to go for a conviction we're going
to investigate we're going to arrest
the democrats won't just sit back and
allow that to happen it's going to be
the same policies which is just a powder
keg and then and then you get some kind
of chaos collapse or otherwise so i
don't know what the answers are i just
know that for me sitting back watching
democrat corruption
sitting back and seeing the media lie
and work in collusion with the
democratic establishment seeing big tech
do all of these things and then seeing
the established republicans who are all
in on the game sitting on their hands
the whole time i'm just like
we need people like
lauren bobert or marjory taylor green or
thomas massey more
freedom caucus individuals who are just
going to be alike we're going to we're
gonna push back we're gonna say no we
need term limits too and especially for
the administrative state as well like
that trump's military were lying to him
about the troops in syria about the
numbers of troops we had in syria that's
an administrative problem those guys
should have been term limited out i mean
the president obviously can hire whoever
wants but i think we should have some
legal restrictions there maybe the
president shouldn't be able to hire
whoever he wants or she wants
um but a lot of those people you're
talking about are not hired by the
president a lot of those people are
these career you know that sort of is
where the deep state is from is these
career people who are actually
explicitly not hired by the president
right those are the careers the people
hired by the president or the politicals
that's where you have when you're a
democrat you have two forces aligned in
your favor you have the career employees
and the political appointees when you're
a republican especially when you're
trump you have the careers aligned
against you and then you have your
political appointees so you're still
fighting
your own government employees who are
also impossible to fire when they're
doing a bad job but
being able to reform the career
hires in the government would be a huge
win for taxpayers for the government
transparency for anything like that how
do you get anything done
i you know it's like there's like 10
members of congress who are actually
like hey maybe we should change this and
everyone else is like don't rock the
boat we get to eat steak houses the
government pays for it i want to go home
i mean it is a problem with both sides
obviously of just sort of the
lackadaisical attitude as we have these
massive problems but again that's why
it's important for any voter in any
district in the country to go sort of
ask the people who are asking for their
vote hey what do you plan on actually
doing when you're in there and that's
why i can say in good conscience to
voters
yes i understand i'm 25 but look at what
my reporting has already done when it's
something like education for example
i got the governor of tennessee to quash
planned social justice grants at state
schools in tennessee a professor reached
out to me he said hey i teach at the
university of memphis which is a public
school in tennessee and our school is
bribing professors to incorporate the
university of memphis social justice
principles why does the school even have
those things in tennessee i don't know
uh and i said i've never seen that in
the years that i have been a higher ed
and k-12 education activist so i wrote
the article exposing that this program
exists i contact the governor of
tennessee's office i said hey what is
going on here and then the next week
that program is cancelled so being able
like you can use governmental powers for
good to stop leftist insanity but you
need people in government who are
actually going to either expose it
themselves or when contacted with these
sorts of tips actually do things about
it
have you gotten the trump bump yet has
trump shouted you out uh not yet
actually uh we'll see we'll see what his
interest level in maryland is he
endorsed thomas massey right you did
yeah amazing which is crazy because he
was all against massey last cycle right
right yeah i remember i remember and uh
would you sign on to thomas massey's
legislation to
the department of education will end
december 31 2022
uh well obviously i would not be in
office by december 31st 20th okay
whatever it is like um what i mean ask
is do you agree with thomas massey
saying let's shut this down
i think that probably does make sense a
lot of these federal departments are
only making things much worse um
especially the department of education
i would need to figure out what the
actual ramifications of that would be
but i am i mean we need to drastically
slash the size of government and
especially things like this was a
priority during the trump admin in the
early years moving things like the
department of the interior to
the interior you know there's no reason
for all of these government agencies to
be based in dc especially when they're
like the bureau of land management put
that in a state like arizona or nevada
you know if there was i would never want
to be in politics but if there was one
reason to be in politics is just to do
like exactly what thomas massey did
i would just be like i have a whole
bunch of bills drafted up this
department will end this
the department
you know what i would do though i
wouldn't write i wouldn't draft a bill
that says like the department of
education will end on this date it will
be called the congressional salary yes
yeah exactly and it will be like
brilliant line one all members of
congress shall receive a salary equal to
you know whatever percentage equal to
the department of energy's staff in the
five years from now which will be zero
dollars he calculated about 400 million
a year that we would save if we got
gutted that but then he thought we could
repurpose the money to like individual
school choice um methods and things like
that i would just make a bunch of bills
that were all just raises for congress
yeah but then like in the fine print at
the bottom of that also the department
of education will end honestly you could
put it in the first line i don't even
think they read that far into it they
just see that you know they see it's
called the jobs builder like all right
i'm for the jobs bill well this is what
we heard from um from the frida's caucus
crew that
there's some guy who's not pelosi and
he's like uh next up is this bill
you know the the jobs act reform bill
all in favor on the democrat side
all in favor on the republican side
it passes bang next so you just make
like the congressional salary raise bill
and then it would just have like a whole
bunch of stuff in it like this is gone
this is gone
i wonder if you know i would just that's
all i would do i would be like the
saving children and and preserving the
family act and or i'd make like the um
the pro lgbtq protect our children bill
and it says the national firearms act
will sunset as of december 31st 2022 and
that's all it will say have nothing to
do with anything else once it's a 50 pay
cut effect
once you're officially a west virginia
guy i mean we would make a pretty
interesting delegation across the river
from each other we would just be you
know we'd be we'd be quite a duo here so
i'm just saying it's the dissolve
governmental department's caucus
all we do i'd love to see a video chat
show i don't know what you call it i
don't like calling a podcast cause
that's just an ipod thing and i'm not an
apple zealot but i think they just
discontinued ipods today oh okay well
you haven't heard about that i heard
about that podcasts are gone i mean uh
podcasting we should have known this
but like like aoc does for instance
where you just you video chat with your
friends or your followers or whoever the
your voters or whatever you call people
it gets a little culty because they'll
worship you and like follow you into
anything which could be bad if you go
crazy but it's a great way to stay keep
people informed to answer their
questions and to create real people that
will stay with you through the process i
disagreed with your earlier point on how
we should have like
much more teleworking in government i
think it should the government should be
way more accessible to you than it is
right now so any way we can make people
who feel disaffected and disconnected
from the government and from sort of
their community we should do more of
that and again i mean like parts of
western maryland have not heard from
their representative in decades so it is
like the more ways we can reach more
people and that aoc's credit is
something she does do well as she does
sort of engage people our age
in politics granted in left-wing
insanity but there's nothing stopping
conservatives and republicans from also
trying to
make politics something that people who
are normal want to engage and feel like
is actually can be a meaningful vehicle
for change would you vote for boots on
the ground in ukraine
uh no i don't think so what about you
don't think so i don't i
you're already putting me in congress so
i know
what what about like weapons and stuff i
don't have a problem sending weapons
yeah yeah i mean i i recognize that too
i'm like i have all these questions as
if you were a member of congress and so
you're like you're not yeah but i do
think it's i think it's important i mean
you know you're running in the primary
so the problem with sending weapons in
my opinion anyway the problem was
sending weapons to azov which is like
the nazi battalion of the ukrainian army
that's freedom fighters they call them
they're called freedom fighters when
they're on our side then they call them
terrorists when they're not and is that
it one day they may not be on our side
anymore now they have american weapons
i mean look we left an entire arsenal to
the taliban so i don't i don't know
where to factor that into this you know
the i i think that the surrender of
afghanistan was sort of like the obama
red line in 2013 that set the stage for
you know that was the first domino to
fall that led to serious consequences so
when we abandoned afghanistan for a
failed photo op that said to china yeah
you guys can do whatever you guys want
domestically you get spy on all of our
olympians i reported on how one of the
sponsors of the chinese genocide
olympics was ifly tech which the chinese
government uses to voice recognize
uyghur dissidents and that was a
straight-up sponsor that was actually
the official translation tool that
american athletes would use when
communicating to other athletes so china
was straight up storing our athletes
voice recognition so we we supported
that with the weakest diplomatic boycott
known to mankind and
after that obviously russia invades
ukraine all of democratic foreign policy
is united around the goal of giving iran
nuclear weapons because keep in mind
none of this is happening in a vacuum
right russia invades ukraine meanwhile
putin's guy in vienna is negotiating an
iran deal on behalf of the united states
of america so biden can't cut off
russian oil because that would piss off
the guys who are negotiating to sprint
to give iran nuclear weapons he finally
relents on buying russian oil and then
says all right you know what instead of
russian oil we're going to buy
venezuelan oil because what does the
administration hate american jobs and
american oil because it's beholden to
left-wing activists so
anyway all of that is to say none of the
foreign policy failures of the biden
administration happen in a vacuum and
the failure in afghanistan set the stage
for massive failures that are already
happening that are aided and abetted by
democrats teleworking because either
they're discussing classified
information in unclassified settings
like they're zooming in from starbucks
while they should pretend to be working
or they're not discussing anything
classified and they have no idea that
russia is about to invade ukraine or
that china is eyeing taiwan that you
know people with brains can just figure
out is obviously happening they should
not be using zoom they need encrypted
exactly source technology that they can
watch the other that's a crazy task so
just for some reason i pulled up the
caning of charles sumner on wikipedia
did you know that the kane used to
attack charles sumner is on exhibit at
the old state house in boston
so this was basically just like right
before the civil war
this uh southern democrat slave owner
guy i think he was a pro-slavery guy
brutally beat
charles summer with a cane nearly
killing him
because like the other guy gave a speech
i just i'm just wondering are we
anywhere near something like that
occurring at this point just with the
hyperpolarization currently on the rise
i wonder if maybe in 2026 i don't know
because there are protect like our
political leaders are a protected class
so i don't know i there are certain
leaders who are dissidents who i could
see the establishment being more
comfortable seeing that happen to but do
you guys remember i believe about 10
years ago there was a camera was a
senator a congressman but he said you
lie to obama
yeah everyone lost their minds how could
this happen like they used to beat each
other they used to duel what are you
talking about
he heckled him while he was actually
lying by the way yeah he pointed out
that he was lying and that was so
unprecedented and horrible so everyone
has a very weak stomach for basically
anything confrontational
but at the same time uh you know if it's
someone outside of the establishment of
course or it's someone who's a target of
the radical lefts hatred then we can
absolutely destroy them this definitely
wouldn't happen now because democrats
literally don't show up in the capitol
[Laughter]
they would say words are violence you
know you tweeted something mean but you
can't actually have physical violence
when no one shows up to work burning
down buildings isn't violence right yeah
exactly right just the voice of the
unheard is rioting the only people who
do show up for the most part are the
republicans on the freedom caucus
um they i mean i mean basically when i
was doing the reporting every republican
office was they were there was in there
yeah wow
i just looked up house of shame is from
bbc house of shame parliament brawls
around the world it's not uncommon for a
parliament to go at each other those are
my words not the article's words but
you'll see video of it maybe you could
consider it uncommon it's not rare or
maybe you consider it rare but it
doesn't not happen there are videos like
i think in eastern europe of them just
the whole parliament just going just
massive
let me
step in and stop it i mean what
authority do people let me let me read
this the aftermath of the caning the
episode revealed the polarization in
america which had now reached the floor
of the senate sumner became a martyr in
the north and brooks a hero in the south
northerners were outraged
that right there just reading that i'm
like
if
no matter what happens
in terms of conflict in with the with
the ever increasing polarization in this
country both sides will be happy
whatever happened happened is this
pre-civil war this is just before the
civil war well also it's important
remember that with a lot of the culture
war issues and the things people are
really riled up about the actual
establishment politicians either don't
have that much of a difference or they
don't talk about it so we would never
see nancy pelosi caning mitt romney
right or something along those lines
because even though there are different
parties
they're totally in bed together
ultimately but as i mentioned earlier i
could see you know maybe somebody like
uh marjorie taylor green or someone who
is really genuinely an outsider being
you know a target for
some kind of misconduct or serious
misconduct i mean we already saw them
try to use the legal system to punish
her for her political views so i don't
know man the united states is unique
because if people are armed you just
don't mess with people like that they
were armed back then too
maybe but not maybe i don't know do they
open carry on the floor of congress
i wasn't around in the 1850s no no i'm
talking about today no no no i mean
you you can i'm pretty sure doesn't
lauren bobert keep her going with her
this was a squabble earlier this year
was some members of the republican party
were bringing weapons to the house floor
because remember they put up the metal
detectors and some members would say
whether they were armed they'd just walk
around and get fined um
i don't think you can open carrie on the
capitol grounds i definitely don't think
so she might have it but not bring it to
the floor i don't know i don't know how
i feel about that
yeah i can unders i can understand
issues of like
functions of justice
where we have certain restrictions
but i kind of lean towards people should
be allowed to keep and bear arms
that's like like
you know if you go if you go back in
time i'd imagine being in the capital
you'd want to be able to protect it if
an attack happened or something happened
and what if a crazy person walks in you
know so i don't know i kind of think
members of congress yeah you get i think
i think everybody should be able to open
you get a situation you can get a
situation where like one person in the
parliament i'll use examples that have
happened in the past goes at another
member of parliament and then like
the the securities just watching because
they don't know what to do and if
whoever's running the parliament's like
don't do anything to the security guards
then they're just gonna wait and then it
becomes partisan really like if your
life is being threatened on the floor of
congress you have a right to defend your
life
in my opinion
and constitutionally yeah
although i don't know what the laws but
constitutionally then we can talk about
the laws made after that
you know one thing i wanted to mention
about what you were saying earlier
about the government of china the
government of china is the republic of
china based in taiwan the uh oppressive
i guess
uh conquering or a um what do you call
that see this is a great fact check we
need more we need more of these sorts of
yeah the republic of china was pushed
out by the ccp uh during mao's
revolution and the ccp is actually an
occupying force thank you
i'm just reading the timeline of events
of the civil war it's crazy you people
need to understand that uh years go by
before anything anything like
1859 you know john brown's raid on the
harpers ferry armory this is like years
before some of these massive war like
battles that were fought and it's like
1860 and then it goes on for years it's
just this was life for everybody it's
kind of crazy huh
yeah there's that uh there's that quote
i think it might have even been lenin
who did not say many wise things but he
said that there are there are decades
where nothing happens and then days
where decades happens or something like
that
61 to 65 1861 1865 just imagine for four
years it's just there's war going on and
people are killing each other and it's
just crazy
crazy
and it wasn't that many lifetimes ago
no yeah no we're an amazing we have an
opportunity to pick our future right now
guide the consciousness if we want to go
to war we could send people to war if we
want peace we can do that too it's
but it requires dedication and humility
you got to be humiliated in front of
people to allow yourself to be a pariah
i
i i kind of love the people
i kind of feel like it's inevitable
and it's not i mean
i just look right now the left
they're putting out videos where they're
like why aren't the justices being
arrested for perjury because they said
under oath that roe v wade was settled
law but now they're saying it's not and
they're saying which is a ridiculous
argument but it doesn't matter
these millennials who are arguing this
will one day inherit the courts
and that ideology is present within them
they will be like well this you did say
it was settled law and then you might
argue like yeah but i never said i
wouldn't overturn it so what you're
going to jail because i'm the ag now you
may be right that if we keep doing the
government as it's written with the
modern technology it's going to
inevitably lead to worship not say that
at all well you're saying it's
inevitable and i think the reason is
because with modern technology the
ability to create a cult within like
three days uh with through social media
is super dangerous for our form of
group communication government where
that's just the speed at which they can
form i mean information always traveled
i'm just saying
with
one side saying why isn't trump being
arrested the other side saying why isn't
hillary being arrested what happens when
either of those sides actually gains
control of an institutions
uh of an institution that can enforce
this matabee described it as the um
afraid exactly said it's the moment that
two different cars are rushing towards
the capitol
and what they're trying to do is get
there first to arrest the specific
person
and then both groups jump out and then
point at each other you're under arrest
and so that's what he's seen in various
countries with civil war
so if right now you have people
screaming
why isn't trump being criminally charged
and these are the aoc type progressives
that are getting into congress and these
are the politically active young gen z
millennial types who are going to be
running going to be working in congress
then you have the populist money types
who are saying why wasn't hillary
arrested why isn't joe biden being
arrested
what happens when they gain power so
whichever faction gains control of the
institution
is going to i think wield it against the
other which will result in the other
side saying no
and then
some kind of conflict you surely need to
empower the people the politicians are
not the answer it's good to have people
functioning with politics obviously but
no the power is with the huma the
individual in this country always has
been
well let's uh let's go to super chats if
you have not already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it head
over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have that members only
segment coming up around 11 p.m
which we record and then it goes up and
uh you're also helping support
alternative infrastructure because our
website is hosted on rumble which means
the more customers they can get the more
you support businesses that use rumble
the more you are building up this
ecosystem of alternatives to silicon
valley so thank you so much for being
members
let's read what we got
jesse says my lib sister has her pup
watch chicken city she's gonna freak out
when she learns their far right chickens
oh yeah they are they're they're all far
right
although i think vanessa is uh is it
antifa so we gotta we gotta watch out
for oh what uh what tipped you off there
she's uh uh she she's she's uh all black
yeah oh she's she's she's she's in black
block yeah that's right yeah
yep
yeah well let's see if she'll take off
her outfit not dorothy though but it's
also because vanessa looks angry vanessa
so there's two uh bart plymouth rock
chickens we have and vanessa's eyes are
her brow is always full and she's like
looking around like and then dorothy's
eyes are always like up and like dopey
she's like oh
i just it's really weird they have that
expression on their face i'm you can
tell them apart that way they're
identical otherwise
all right
lee uh leandro brady says 2 000 mules
per gallon oh excellent excellent
joe taylor says tim think of this six
dollars a gallon with each tank on a
semi being around 350 gallons times two
you're talking three thousand dollars to
fill a semi truck they do that once or
twice a day yo i saw a meme
where someone had to spend like thirteen
hundred dollars to fill up his tank a
trucker
how that's gonna that's gonna translate
to all of your goods yep yep that is
insane wow better start growing food
yeah i uh i have a trucker friend how do
we grow gas i have a trucker friend who
gets eight miles to the gallon with his
truck and he's talking about how
unbelievably expensive it is to fill up
his semi there's like this cool way we
come back from this there's a technology
this japanese inventor was working on
where he would take plastic and put it
in a high pressure high heat environment
with no oxygen and then it reconverts
the plastic into oil and then you can
refine it back into petroleum or diesel
all right ghost crusader says there is
no corn at my local supermarkets new
york city not canned corn
no corn
wow what do you eat
me personally kimchi no if there's no
corn left what are you going to do
cabbage cabbage it's also one people
don't realize kale everything is made of
corn in this country yeah we manufacture
everything from for decades we looked at
products and said how can we uh make
that out of corn instead people don't
understand how screwed we are if we then
we had cows and we were like how can we
make them out of corn instead we started
feeding them corn instead of grass
it's insane all right black lion grunt
says i summon ultra maga with 10 000 hit
points destroys all enemies that opposes
freedom
ultra maga
mxp says timmy if you ever go on rogan
again can you talk about the great reset
also have more guests on your show to
talk about it sure
yeah that was actually something i
wanted to bring up when me and you and
alex and michael malus and everybody and
joe were on the show i was like i should
have brought up cloud schwab we didn't
get into it but next time maybe we
should have uh like james lindsay with
alex jones it'll be good we'll talk
about klaus schwab
all right earl graham says as a member
of tim cast i demand you bring roberto
senior onto one of your live shows to
replace ian
i'm not i'm not against it roberto
senior is officially in sex jail ah so
you finally locked the aggressor up well
because we're retiring him
yeah we could only have one dominant
rooster at a time and and roberto jr has
now like has fully grown so roberto and
his son are now
there it's too much for the chickens and
they're starting to get hurt because the
dude's just going at it too much you
know is that an allegory for when
there's two superpowers one of them
eventually what's that loss
yeah i'm just saying that three times
fast thucydides
rising young rooster threatens the aging
and decrepit rooster and then war is
inevitable yeah that's actually what
happens
so roberto jr has been slowly pushing on
roberto i think he's bigger than his dad
now
because he's a beast yeah he's big i
like his song too oh he's a bit more
chill than roberto is roberto senior is
like aggressive and like angsty but i
think it's because they thought he was a
girl when he was born and it is 20 22.
so he was supposed to be cold and we
thought we were getting chickens but we
got a rooster in there and i'm like
maybe his son's bigger because something
about roberto was like he was like a low
t rooster or something like that
yeah i don't know
all right colonel panic says tim and
king i think we all agree that youtube
is less than stellar but is rumble
really better or simply different in
rumble terms of service it sounds like
they reserve the right to take your
account and content
act 17 acts apologetics made a video
about this
yeah i don't think they're they're
perfect they're an alternative and
they're competition so that's what's
good
if there were two youtubes that were
identical and they were actually
competing it'd be a good thing but
rumble's actually competition so
paul jones says big fan of the show the
show the other day about daryl davis was
incredibly embarrassing for daryl davis
at first i was angry you weren't
confronting him but you let him dig his
own grave keep up your good work
you can't say it's embarrassing for
someone else that's that's virtue
signaling
only you can say if something's
embarrassing for you let other people
decide how they feel it's called cringe
cringe is when you feel embarrassment
for someone else yeah but that's virtu
if you say it out loud it becomes virtue
signaling no virtue signaling is when
you pretend to support something to
attract attention from those who also
claim to support it or if you're just
okay i'm not gonna argue this right now
it's most of left-wing instagram
yeah they're all just trying to get
clicks and likes
bert usa says imagine trump's head on
all might's body then imagine the left
facing off against this plus ultraman
now we wait for the united states of
smash or at the very least a delaware
smash
so someone may yes ha if you if you guys
know what my hero academia is you
understand you understood those
references but somebody actually made a
comic called walmite where trump is
almight superhero
and they call him walmite
all right
paul jones says you gotta you guys are
right about how if it was the right
they'd be locked up asap it's funny how
biden campaigned on being a moderate and
unity but he's been nothing but
dismissive and fear-mongering i'm not
surprised by that
all right carolyn clark says watch 2000
mules tim and get off that fence big fan
would like to apply for room mother 54
gen x rules love from roanoke texas very
cool yeah i we we haven't had a chance
to check out 2000 mules but we will
mention it when we can mention it well
figured out i had a name of this
japanese inventor that made this oil
machine i was talking about his name's
like akinori ito and the machine is
called the blessed machine it'll put
plastic in there and then it converts it
into oil
cameron miller says first time super
chat for my son's birthday huxley he
turns eight today and his biggest
birthday wish is to see tim minus the
beanie too bad huxley you can't always
get what you want wait until you're nine
important important important lesson for
life but happy birthday nonetheless
happy birthday you can keep asking
though yeah dream crusher
cameron miller says second super chat
ever have you heard of king randall and
what he is doing in albany georgia he
would be a great guest i don't know who
is that does anybody know
king randall
did he claire did he declare
independence and assert himself as a
monarch randall king i don't think so
king randall mike s says the real reason
hassan will only do zoom debates is so
that he can get instant answers during
the debate from his discord followers
i've heard that um
perhaps i don't know
i think there's two fair points hassan
hosts his own show he has no obligation
and it would be it's like hey stop doing
your show to do mine like why would
anyone do that i wouldn't want to do
that and then the other thing is
people like i've told everybody on the
show like we're all sitting here with
computers so bring a computer and also
we will pull up anything you reference
if you want to counter our point and so
we've actually done that with
conflicting studies before but you know
whatever nobody is obligated to come on
this show i'll just explain that i think
their
la prominent left personalities
typically won't come on the show because
they know they'll lose they'll lose the
argument
and they're not they're not willing to
come on to have that conversation
official debates real debates if you're
going to have a real debate you need a
moderator you need to have a point
system i'm not interested in debating
someone i'm interested in having a
conversation about ideas
but you know i got to say it again
hunter avalon when he came on the show
had no idea what he was talking about
with ukraine barismo and hunter and joe
and hunter biden and so he tries to
assert himself like that didn't happen
and then when i mentioned
joe biden said
you're not getting the billion dollars
unless you fire the prosecutor and he
said that never happened because he gets
he probably got his news from from cnn
another fake news so i just pulled the
video up and clicked play and i'm like
there it is when uh what do you have to
say about when they were investigating
zlatsky or or barisma was luchetsky
working at the company still zlatchevsky
had fled the country
and then when joe biden got the
prosecutor fired he came back
and then when donald trump came in and
said i want this investigated he fled
the country it's funny how that works i
don't fault people necessarily for not
knowing these sorts of things because
remember it took our esteemed colleagues
in the mainstream media two years to
verify that hunter biden's laptop was
real so there are some things where it
is actually incredibly difficult to
get actual information
found out now that said if you're coming
on this show or any show is a so-called
expert on burisma and you don't know
basic facts about hunter biden and the
biden family then that's where it
becomes a problem but it's very hard to
actually find you know these basic
things about the biden family this is
why i think many of these people don't
want to come on the show because we're
going to be like hey let's have a very
serious political conversation about
corruption and then all of a sudden it's
like oh i'm forced to actually confront
my ideas that are based on on falsehoods
the other thing i think will happen too
is that we if we brought on like a left
populist
and then you know someone like steve
bannon
and then they were like i think we
should tax the rich and then steve
bannon goes i completely agree then the
headline would be like leftist degrees
with steve bannon and they'd be like no
no no yeah yeah exactly and you have to
consider oh sorry it would be like who's
right would be the question get it yeah
yeah well no i mean
[Laughter]
you can't just tell us it's funny
but
it's it's also such a huge part of the
the fan base that they've courted these
are people who will intentionally just
go out of their way and operate in the
most bad faith manner possible so they
can find something you said that makes
you right wing that's the funny thing
like um michael malus often brings up
that he'll say biden is bad for x reason
and they'll say yeah well trump did why
and he'll be like yes i agree what does
that have to do with what i said like
the people can only think it's either
your for your trump or your for biden
you can't criticize you know both but
this also does get to the mainstream
media's problem and why the trump
presidency broke them was all of their
subscribers are these resistance people
who the second they start criticizing
democrats are going to rage unsubscribe
right so now that they cultivated this
subscriber base based on combing through
the dumpsters of trump tower and the
trump hotel in dc if you're actually
going to basically copy and paste my
reporting and other people's reportings
about joe kiani about jennifer granholm
about gina raimondo any of these sorts
of things you're going to confront your
subscribers with a reality which is
reality that they don't want to confront
so they've they've dug this hole and
they have no way of actually being able
to get out you know you know what i've
encountered though
when it comes to
the
the the quote-unquote right as it's
often described is such a big umbrella
that you'll end up with tons of people
aggressive
trump supporting
not necessarily trump supporters
post-liberal libertarian so if i make a
video
and i say something about the
quote-unquote right or constitutionalist
position
i'll get a bunch of comments from people
who are like hey tim you actually messed
up on this one and it's very like normal
the left will purposefully take things
out of context to lie about me so like i
once did a video about
hybrid vigor
there's a scientific study that found
that people who have genetics from
different parts of the planet tend to
have like less disease and stuff and i
was making a point about like why racism
was bad and stupid
the left took the video screenshots of
it and then misrepresented what it was
about and claimed it was a racist video
that hated race mixing when it was the
complete inversion of what it was and i
was like wow
like when you when you see that i made a
video where i was like here's my
argument on gun control and i got a
bunch of conservatives and libertarians
being like you're wrong and here's why
and i went well those are really good
points actually and then i changed my
position the left just starts crapping
all over me and making up what my
positions were and i was like dude what
i was agreeing with you they don't care
well i mean yeah they've adopted the
strategy of just just like sort of
stomping their foot and screaming you're
bad you're bad you don't feel bad for
the people i tell you to feel bad for
and you don't um you know sit there and
apologize for things you had nothing to
do with so that's basically it you've
got to yeah let's take it and feed them
like a feral animal then they'll cool up
to you slowly let's read more super
chats we've got powder who says i work
at a corner store in california the
price for our weekly chicken strip order
has gone up one thousand dollars food
shortages are coming get prepared i'm
talking about if you can provide food to
these people they'll they'll believe you
and get on your side that's how it
always is like in in venezuela the
national guard gets fed so they'll do
what they're told because they want to
live
nathan leonard says forget food
shortages hospitals across the country
are now short on iv contrast dye meaning
life-saving medical tests cannot be
performed oh it won't end there
it is going to get substantially more
intense
these shortages
baby formula is just the beginning i
wonder if we can make that i was looking
into it a little i couldn't find
anything what's it made of
i don't know yet but i would imagine we
could concoct something that would be
pretty similar yeah
pediatricians specifically tell people
not to make their own i was actually
looking at this today um part of the
problem is that it contains a lot of
vitamins and minerals and it is based on
cow's milk i've also
i've heard that goat's milk is a good
substitute in some instances um but
there you can also sign up for something
like the la lache league if you're
having trouble finding formula and
there's all sorts of stuff you can do
you just gotta research it
darth ritz says matt's a cool dude but
most of maryland's gopr rhinos hogan
being okay with critical race theory is
not very cash money matt please don't
become a rhino i will just quickly say
on that point i actually was one of the
reporters who first exposed critical
race theory's existence in maryland
public schools
in anne arundel county and in montgomery
county i've covered both removing police
from schools and the leftist insanity in
curricula um and you know there's sort
of this common trope amongst left-wing
activists that critical race theories
and tonics we all know this but uh a
parent in anne arundel county simply
forwarded me an email from the anne
arundel county board of education which
confirmed to parents yes critical race
theory is taught in anne arundel county
schools the specific article that i
wrote about it it was one of the most
insane things in education it's from a
pre-k through fifth grade school so
four-year-olds in maryland public
schools in international county were
being taught that uh japanese internment
during world war ii when we interned
japanese-american citizens is like
securing the southern border so and that
wasn't isn't necessarily critical race
theory but in the course of that story
you know
i got an email from the board of ed
education saying yeah we teach critical
race theory here in annapolis i'm like
oh my god what's the story called um
look up annapolis critical race theory
free beacon and
japanese internment will pop up but with
the free beacon you really cannot find
our articles on the internet unless you
add free beacon to the search but look
up
uh
free beacon japanese internment someone
can put it in the chat free beacon
japanese and tournament maryland public
school and you'll find it
clayton ostrang says ian have you read
the bible had discussions with a priest
or attended church for an extended
period of time i think it would benefit
you in your discussions about the bible
and what sheamus and catholics believe i
got baptized and it was the creepiest
thing one of the creepiest things i've
ever experienced i went to a church camp
a methodist church camp and this guy was
much older than me i was like 12 or 13
and he was like 18 or something sat next
to me with his tight shorts on was like
now say you take jesus into your heart
and i went i take jesus into my heart
he's like okay now you're baptized and
he had the bible it was so weird well
that's not no you you described one
creepy experience with one
christian well yeah like maybe you just
had a weird crazy experience bro i
definitely did yeah but that's extremely
disturbing and all of us all had to do
was say it out loud and now it's real
come on here's the here's a lifelong
uh journey to be if you want to live
like christ the segment
being referenced here is um when you
mentioned that the the the mike the mic
check my check shutdown was like very
religious
and i i've spent time
we used to go to mass twice a week when
i was in catholic school we left when i
was about 10 years old and so what i can
say is we we all knew exactly what we
were saying and reading from the book as
was being explained to us i feel like it
was never adequately explained to me
which is why i left and there's a big
difference between reading from a book
and hearing the priest talk to you about
what's going on
we had the was it the procession of the
cross is the crucifixion what was it all
the stations of the crosstalk
yeah procession and so we had that on
the wall and we had everything explained
in great detail i just felt like the
teachers didn't actually explain like to
me what it all meant when i go to
protests and people are saying gibberish
words and they don't know what the
protest chan is it's a big difference
yeah organized disorganized organized
religion is there's problems with
organization as well but you know there
is organization this is why it's
important also to listen to joe biden
speak instead of read the text of his
words right because if you read the text
of his words especially when you were
talking about the daily mail with jen
saki earlier it can be made to sound
coherent but when you watch it it's like
whoa this is not the same thing even
conservatives do this yeah uh
conservative
outlets tend not to as much but biden
will say something like
come on you know i got a
economy you know it's a
you got to make it better
come on and then the news will say joe
biden said we have to make the economy
better or quote the economy must be
better and it's like no he didn't he
stuttered it mumbled sputtered and was
confused the whole time write down if
you wrote down quotes from joe biden it
would be full of ellipses um's eyes
stutters broken words and gibberish you
put the word pause in parentheses at
least you do in the theater when you
write a script no exactly and whenever
they wrote down trump's words they
included every filler word every ah
every um every little pause they did
everything they could to represent how
unclean normal natural speech generally
is and then with joe biden they clean up
everything he says even though he sounds
like he's slurring half the time all
right straight says bill gates tweeted
he has covid and then disabled replies
that's not surprising
fireside story says ian you are telling
me that that the programmer and creator
of the big machine we call the universe
can't go to one of his programs and make
it pregnant well i'm saying you have no
way of knowing
so why would you believe it no way
knowing what if god impregnated mary
i mean if you believe that the gospel
writers and the other scriptural writers
are reliable sources on the other things
that they do i don't believe cnn is a
reliable source i don't know wait hold
on a second they have a show called
reliable sources yeah that proves that
that is but hold on to say well like the
bible so the bible isn't true because
cnn isn't true well i just think i have
no way to verify and fact check where
they got their sources where it comes
from who they were i don't know but have
you looked into it i mean have you ever
identified this i think
i think i'll say this ian
you should read the bible and go to a
church not to become faithful but to
hear what they're saying you're right
about that to make the argument and
second i would actually say you should
read like philosophy various various
philosophical concepts and ideas on
knowledge wisdom truth and something no
i know it's a tough it's a tough life
because when you are a philosopher you
don't really read what other people
thought you just tell people what you
think so that was my life up until now
but i understand the organization is so
important i think i think the issue is
you are right that you can't prove
but
there's there's deep philosophical
questions about why people choose to
believe
and why people think things are true
some things are easily discerned as
objectively true like i know that if i
throw a rock in a window is a great
chance the window will break however not
all windows will break what if it turns
out it was bulletproof and the rock just
bounces off so you might think you know
something and then your expectations are
shattered when the window doesn't
shatter
i think some things we can prove but i
think most things we believe are
unproven almost i would say 99 of what
humans believe is completely unproven i
i just got a book called do them to them
i mean to them i got a book called
creating christ how roman emperors
invented christianity i mentioned it on
the show a few weeks ago maybe a month
ago that uh there's this concept that
the romans created christianity to
disempower the jews because the jews
were a threat to their imperial
authority and i like that but but you're
right tim that i shouldn't just read
books that i want to verify my own
beliefs about i should be reading the
bible the other stuff as well to
understand the entire context yeah i
think thank you
oh sorry ian have you ever placed
graphene under an electron microscope
not yet baby and you just believe
everything you've said about graphene
such a follower now see this is this
this is important that you'd come out
and be like how do i know the bible's
real how do i know but you've never as
well i've read bits of the bible but as
much as you have have proselytized the
power of graphene you never actually
looked under it under a microscope you
want me to start a graphene company i
can sense no no no i'm challenging your
position
no but i would not tell you i would not
stake my life on this but i don't i mean
i believe it because science the
scientific method's awesome and i've
read enough scientific articles about it
and looked at images of what they tell
me is microscopy and stuff like that oh
and
and i'm sure that they're i mean there's
a shroud of turin i got a coin for
sheamus that's uh allegedly one of the
three wise men's currency or whatever
there's snap there's a bunch of that
kind of stuff my point is i do think
some things are yes electron microscopes
you can do the work i'm just saying not
that things sure aren't true not that
religion is true not true i'm saying if
you're going to
advocate the power of graphene with such
fervor i would at least expect you to
stand by your own standard and have done
the personal research into analyzing
yourself i was in south america to start
a graphing company i got i guess called
derailed and came here but i mean i'm
glad i'm here well there are people in
south america who are on missions to
preach the word of the gospel
it doesn't mean they've proven it's true
and you haven't proven no i haven't is
what it is no but it's not my why i'm
here and i would not proselytize this
stuff apparently boring's awesome hey i
tried to read the quran i bought a quran
because i'm like i gotta know it is so
hard it was so hard for me to read
because it's a lot about he he makes so
he says a word as if it already everyone
already knows what it means and then he
uses and he capitalizes the word in the
sentence and it's really weird like it's
really culty and like
you gotta already wanna believe it to
believe it this is exactly like marxism
where you read karl marx and you're like
this is nonsensical gibberish with a lot
of mathematical formulas that don't make
sense and so you sort of know that all
of the people who are you know
protesting in all these streets have
never opened das capital or any of the
marxism that they claim to believe but
anyway that's also a religion let's
let's read more super chats
all right mr ross lyon says ultra maga
adeptus magaz purging progressive heresy
across the imperium in the name of god
emperor trump
well there you go all right pete hodges
says funny story i was on a project in
maryland in 2015. i never believed the
trump candidacy was viable until i moved
to eastern maryland and talked to the
locals
i've heard this i was talking to um max
max kaiser and stacey
and they were mentioning how they were
in europe
and they kept hearing everyone hated
trump but then when they landed back in
the u.s and saw the trump signs
everywhere they were like he's going to
win the media is totally wrong about
this people people were very much
they were voting for trump man but also
if they didn't run hillary clinton yeah
bernie would be trump i think a lot of
people don't like to hear it but
yo trump won i think by was it like 88
000 votes and across three different
states that pushed him over the edge of
the electoral college yeah hillary
clinton was just not popular
she didn't campaign in wisconsin i mean
i know she didn't want to win i mean
this is classic liberals taking
everything for granted yep
they're they were in a bubble the media
bubble that's that's that's it and it
only got worse
anno says if joe biden did something
illicit while being vp and or president
he should be impeached if you don't
uphold the law for everyone you
effectively have no law which is why i
said the protesters in front of the
justice uh the supreme court justices
homes should be arrested
because that's what the law is for
that's why we have law right
all right the aaron says i'm seeing ted
cruz soon what question should i ask
bitcoin or ethereum no
more seriously that's the future is
crypto if you guys want to talk about
economics and where we're headed as a
country like are you on the ethereum
blockchain ted or you use the bitcoin
blockchain for real
that's my question i don't know what are
your questions for ted cruz i have no
idea
where's the best place to go on vacation
in cancun
yeah
where were you going did you take
mushrooms before you grow your beard
because you look like you had a
psychological awakening
the real hayden says would ian fight a
war for graphene serious question
that's a little vague and so i guess the
answer is like there's a gigantic
graphene mine no russia
we can mine the carbon dioxide out of
the air if there's a
i would no no the answer is no let's say
in the middle of antarctica is this
massive reservoir they find a vein of
just pure graphene and they're like
whoever gains this graphene will have
untold powers and then vladimir putin
like is riding in on like a the massive
russian multi-billion dollar war jet you
have heard the story they have like a
full command center plane that can like
run their whole government or something
like their military and he's going to
get the graphene and the united states
says ian you're the only one we need to
send you in to fight for this graphene
i'd be like well first of all that i'm
the only one there's a problem that i'm
the only one that can do this what's
that i think you would win
i don't even know winning means these
days all right let's read more peter
gohawk says please ask matt if he would
be open to making trump speaker of the
house then impeaching joe kamala and
nancy uh trump has said he does not want
to be speaker of the house so but would
you want him to be speaker of the house
uh i'm not going to make anyone speaker
who doesn't want to be speaker that's a
horrible job that i would not really
wish on on someone who doesn't
desperately want to do that it's just
and then you impeach joe come on it is
sort of like it's that meme where it's
like you know straightforward from here
you know but uh
technically that would be possible but
trump has been asked about this multiple
times would you would you like to be
speaker because a fun fact you know tim
could be speaker of the house if he got
the majority vote you don't have to be a
member of congress to actually be
speaker of the house but i don't think
that trump wants to be a member of
congress i would not accept
the engaged few says tim can you ask
that guy if he'd be willing to introduce
a constitutional amendment repealing the
17th and return the elections of
senators to the state legislatures
pre-17 senators averaged 10 years six
years
am i that am i that guy no uh because no
one knows who their state legislators
are and that's that's why
so i don't know about that i i don't
think that anyone i mean this is an
unfortunate reality is most people pay
very little attention to local politics
national politics sort of consumes
everything i think you would give
elected state legislators way more power
that's that's what actually what it was
yeah the original idea of the senate was
that the state reps would would choose
they would they would all vote and that
it was up to you to vote locally right
and your local reps would then elect a
senator to go to the federal government
to represent the state
and uh the problem the reason they got
rid of it is that they felt that there
was too much back room dealing i was
about to say this sounds like you're
just giving 30 people the ability to
elect a u.s senator but it's so much
easier to get rid of a state rep or a
state senator than it is to get rid of a
senator i think we got to get rid of 17.
but if we if we did remove direct
election of senators though then all of
that energy would then immediately shift
to state rep races absolutely
and and the issue is a state rep has a
much smaller population so it's much
easier to communicate with your local
community and get that rap or senator in
as opposed to a federal level senator
which is the entire state which people
feel helpless
it's like i'm in illinois what's the
point i'm not voting yeah it's like well
imagine if you went around to your local
communities and got the state
legislature now all of a sudden a state
with chicago in it could actually get a
republican senator
so i think it's worth it well in
illinois though the legislature is still
incredibly dominated by democrats as
well yeah i mean it's it's theory i but
no i i
i'm my favorite i like as many people
being involved in elections as possible
i think uh it was it was it was a check
it was the states senate was was
supposed to be the state's
representative represented and the
congress says the people
so i think getting rid of that was a
problem but uh agree disagree all right
yeah you don't have to beat me with the
game over right now
agreeing clover says for seamus and ian
i just found a catholic prophecy called
the hermit of loretto it was found
founded in the 70s saying trump would
serve two terms but they wouldn't be
back to back check it out so be very
careful this is not something that's
actually i mean this is someone who is
catholic who's saying they have a
prophecy that does not mean it's part of
catholic teaching or something that's
been endorsed by the catholic church so
confirmed sheamus confirmed all right i
think ian probably already knew about
that speaks for me yes
all right let's grab just uh we'll grab
a couple more here
mon hoden says i work at walmart and our
store is getting no meat at all tomorrow
we usually get four pallets a day the
food shortage is already here
and that's why uh you know
i've been consistently shouting out
safeandreadymeals.com this is not a
promo i'm just mentioning it and why i
was shocked when the left consistently
was making fun of that idea i don't care
y'all can make fun of it all day and
night doesn't the left also like
use weird things to grow like kombucha
in their own you know little apartments
in brooklyn and now they're mocking
having actual food
in a problem there's an article vice
wrote and they're like where are these
people now and it's like tim poole is
shilling for emergency food and i'm like
i'm going to print that out and frame it
i could probably do it now because the
food shortage is already getting bad and
i'll put it next to all of the
complaints from people in new york where
they're like there's no food in my store
and i'll be like yo the people that
prepare for this stuff
you should still be worried about it
because you don't want to eat emergency
food until you absolutely have to like
when you literally can't get anything
anymore but i'll tell you who's laughing
the preppers
yeah they're sitting on their mound of
three months of beans and they're like
also they probably have a lot of the
corn yeah well they have a lot of
the left has also been saying for years
that we have a catastrophic climate
change problem and the coasts are going
to flood in the world as we know it is
going to end and then they turn around
and call you stupid for having emergency
food
okay build an ark and they're like
you're so dumb yeah and it's like you
told me that everything was like the
world is ending in 12 years but how
about what that creationism museum
actually is the art that they have built
obama buys waterfront property yeah
pelosi too amazing all right everybody
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with all of your friends it
really does help and head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up it'll be published
around 11 p.m
and as a member i just want to stress
again you'll be supporting companies
that use alternative infrastructure we
use rumbles cloud services and rumbles
video service for our website
the more people who start adopting
rumble the more people who who support
businesses that use alternative
infrastructure the more we strip that
power away from silicon valley big tech
hollywood etc you can follow the show at
tim cast irl you can follow me at tim
cast matthew do you want to shout
anything out well thanks so much for
having me on i hope that voters in
western maryland who are listening to
the show of which i know there are many
vote for me on july 19th you can check
out my website matthewfolde.com follow
me it's all matthew foley on all the
platforms and looking forward to the
members only chat got time to start go
uh going knocking on doors we're door
knocking every single weekend through
november so look forward to having uh
super cool yeah oh get right on
my name's shamus i make cartoons at a
youtube channel called freedom tunes i
do them mostly about political matters
and cultural matters so you if you guys
uh are interested in that please go
check it out i think you'll enjoy it i
want to give a shout out to the hermit
of loretto give you a little context the
astonishing 1980 prophecy of president
donald j trump quote donald j trump will
lead america back to god end quote
father giacomo capoberry i don't know
how you something like that
but apparently not catholic it's not
something it's not no yeah it's not like
as a catholic you were required to
believe that i just like to be careful i
like to be very careful because they're
it's not like this is the official
position of the catholic church this is
a catholic hermit who said that this is
a prophecy some number of catholics
believe them i want to know if donald
trump saw that prophecy in 1980 let's
ask him when we said he decided to run
bye everyone
thank you guys very much for tuning in
this evening and joining us for a little
bit of local slash federal level
politics oh you guys may follow me on
twitter mines.com at sourpatchlitz as
well as sourpatchleads.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you